[Music]
so
over double
that is just fantastic
so i'll tell you what we're gonna do
uh hopefully they remember my login and
password
oh please tell me y'all remember my
username and password because i don't
know
oh thank god let's [__] go
all right
so here's what we need to do
we need to play a warm-up game
we're going to play a warm-up game a
five-minute chess
okay
that's a pizza congratulations
i'm so [__] that's outrageous all
right we'll be okay
we like that fun here
my voice is completely shot dude but you
know what you know what
it's all in the spirit of fun you know
it's all in the spirit of fun
so we'll probably be fine and if not
well unlucky rubber ducky
i don't
but mama ain't raised no quitter we are
ranked 275.
you know what we'll probably be fine
we'll probably be good you know right
now i just need to focus on keeping my
fluids up
you know
and maybe we'll be okay
who knows let's just get it underway
boys
let's get this do i remember how to play
the hippo
the problem is i've been messing around
with too many new strats
but the hippo
it's in my [__] blood at this point
what are you gonna do
you go for that you're gonna go for my
[__] rook
you [__] [__]
no [__] you
now what you gonna do boy
yeah now you don't know what the [__] to
do what the [__] is this looney tunes
looking [__] play
are you going to try to take my bishop
[__] you
you go there you turn around trying to
[__] kill my [__] you trying to
checkmate me [__] boy you think i'm
stupid
you better you better back the [__] up
you better back the [__] up
i will [__] eat you alive yeah now
what you [__] coward back the [__] up
yeah i have a gun
yeah
you're damn right
[__] [__]
try it
the again
are you doing [__]
thanks for the horse you [__] [__]
congratulations
wait a minute what are you doing
what now [__] oh [__]
wait is that check man
what am i about to get mated wait no
wait no
wait wasn't that made
am i dumb was that not mate
okay well you know what
you know what it's probably fine
right it's probably good
we're all good
uh
well here we are you know i'm not gonna
lie boys it's not looking good for us
it's not looking good
it's in fact looking quite bad
it's looking pretty bad boy i ain't got
a lot here
uh
yeah it looks pretty bad
huh
well tech suck chess
if i go here it goes there i can pincher
them no doesn't work
ah
that sucks
this really blows
uh i just wanna we're gonna free up my
queen
and now she's free to go over to c8
which is what i was which is what i've
always wanted
ah so now i have a straight shot here i
can also move my little horsey
i can move
my battalion
[Music]
i'll put my queen here i can [__]
castle bro
peep this [__] boy oh now you don't know
what the [__] the thing
take it
take it dumbass
yeah now my king is protected as [__]
you fat nerd
yeah i don't feel good does it
being one-on-one with a real man
hold up i can kill your ass no i can't
but i thought about it
all right you're lucky i have no idea
what the [__] i'm doing right now
one stream that's just dumb
i think
i feel like that's just ceiling is it
not a little bit a little bit silly
a little bit a little bit silly i think
a little bit dumb and silly
so we're going to keep going
um
i'm wearing my turtle shirt today chad
look there's this tiny turtle guy i
bought it in brian when i was with uh
with everyone
i went to um
uh it was it was it was really funny i
don't think a lot of people talked about
how brian was
i don't think a lot of people talked
about it
um
because obviously we have to vlog but of
course we also did things off of streams
i'll give you a little bit behind the
scenes there was a section
um
on the final day or ish final day puppet
theater
thank you so much for the gift it subs
you absolutely legend 20 gifted 90 in
total already
uh with the hype train going on hey if
you want to subscribe or twitch prime or
anything like that it goes to charity so
if you want to at some point now would
be the moment where your money goes to
um cancer research and cancer research
centers and all that kind of stuff
because still
[__] cancer
um
but pretty much uh there was this
alleyway
when i was with
nikki wilbur uh tommy turbo rambo and
and and and and
one other guy from robert's band
and i think that's the group
i don't think i'm forgetting anyone i
think that was the group um we were we
were in like a tiny alleyway
and because we were with such a big
group
uh jack wasn't there because we were
with ash ash thank you ash because we
were with such a big group um
every time one person came up to take
pictures they would always want to take
pictures individually right fully
understandable they want pictures you
know one with fundy one with uh tommy
one would tell one like etc not the
entire group um
and then
by the time one person was gone
um two more had come in
so it would progressively get more and
more and more people and because of that
uh we eventually went to like the tiny
tiny little little stores and stuff we
went into like um
how i accidentally
became the biggest
chess streamer of all time me
how is that possible
oh please don't hurt me
oh my god
oh my god let's get a photo
we got a photo booth right here and i'm
like
i don't really like taking
i photos you big man hey yay
[Music]
i am not a chess streamer i don't know
what i'm doing
i was just trying to draw a line but
accidentally dragged that
am i dead
we can kill him
no what wait what
i want a refund
can i stop my wife
and as much cash as you can carry you
can keep i don't care if you put in your
pockets and your hoodie and your pants
and your shoes you know i still need to
whip out my camera and
put on
a smile
to get my picture taken
paul champs competitor here
oh my god
hey guys welcome to thanks thanks for
the host
yeah moving the pawn out two squares hey
yo this move here is too rare he got the
two pawns out there as friends yeah
night came around yo we ready to end oh
my god the queen making moves already
yeah pull the queen out yo this dude is
heavy yeah and y'all know knights move
at the angle you stepping up the mag
[Music]
welcome to prague champs for presented
by coinbase this is day two of this epic
series of event and i'm going to be
hosting today's action with the one and
only andrea votes andre how are you
doing
i'm so excited for today i mean i've
been hyping up these participants for
months today is going to be a great show
how are you feeling anna
i'm so hyped to see
that the players are already practicing
i've been watching fun these games
earlier tactile was already also of
course trying to get his a game on and
some of the participants are bringing
their own charity initiatives too but
before we get into our charity let's
take a look at the 16 participants of
the fourth edition of pogchamps andrea
any favorites youth in your opinion that
could take away this fourth edition and
take home the trophy see that's a that's
a tricky question because i've coached
so many of these participants i can't
pick one sap nap i trained with for
months cutie i played her dressed as my
sister the other day minx we both did
lessons with um ludwig obviously he's
been training since the very first
pogchamps and i think he's getting very
very close i i couldn't even predict the
favorite how about you anna
i feel the same way it's gonna be a very
exciting event because there are so many
players that have been working really
hard on their chess this last month's or
couple of months for instance in the
case of ludwig he is here back at [__]
jams for the third time and he's saying
a third time chart charm he might win it
with this third time charm and the help
of grandmaster robert hess of course
but okay we're about to see a really
critical moment right here
if the pawn pushes
oh sorry i was looking at the delayed
board
yeah here he has to play his king to f6
yep and he did it
oh no
here he might make a mistake if he
doesn't move his king up and he moves
his king backwards he's going to let the
white king escape
yeah you have to keep the king
shouldered
he didn't shoulder the king here he
didn't and he let the passport run
just make the box smaller man
just make the ball now he's finally got
him accidentally on the edge and he's
gonna deliver checkmate there we go oh
my god he did it well sapnap is up on
time here so he does have
oh i mean it was too hard of a move to
see i i do not blame him uh but if if
harry max sees it we gotta protest
gambit danny andrea has been getting him
i don't know what to say yeah yeah yeah
does he see it could be a
could be a problem
uh oh
does he don't know if he sees it
no
we're botes gambiting all over the a5
square
oh no even taking the knight is better
because then at least he gets a free
piece
he gonna do it
sapnap also just had a reaction sapnap
just saw he's shaking his head oh he
shook his head he knows he got super
lucky oh my gosh
can i freestyle for chess.com
yeah
yeah we on chats.com hmac improvising a
song yeah and you know that i'm blessed
go i just got whooped at chess all good
man i'm about to learn the game hmac
coming off the top with the flames we're
gonna make it happen when i'm on the
scene i'm the most powerful real just
like queen yeah hmac i'll be making
moves every time i'm on man i'm certain
to improve yeah
that amazing freestyle was one of the
highlights of yesterday's show and the
miz bought this gambit but what was not
missed is michelle curry hitting a
thousand rating points that was her goal
eight months of hard work michelle has
put into her journey not just to
participate in pogchamps three but to go
above and beyond trying to hit that
magical rating barrier a thousand rating
points and yesterday she finally reached
it so much work and dedication and that
means that we will soon get to see her
video about her journey in pop gyms and
training even further to get the
thousand
i'm so happy
huge thanks to our sponsors as usual
coinbase and eternal but apart from the
sponsors i also want to definitely give
a shout out to our charity partner rise
above the disorder we are happy to be
supporting rise above the disorder in
their cause to remove the two greatest
barriers to mental health care excess
and affordability started by a world of
worker guild leader in 2013 rhizobal the
disorder has helped tens of thousands of
people all over the world to receive
mental health
free of charge mental health care
if you want to support this very
important initiative please do go to
go.chess.com
red and make your donation chess.com
will be matching every single donation
up to a hundred thousand dollars and
apart from the charity initiative andra
we have three matches coming up next to
today's uh big show basically we are
starting with fondue versus tactile box
box versus just the wings and finishing
perhaps on an even higher note ludwig
versus mr beast a rematch between these
two gentlemen what do you think will
happen in today's show
i mean we have a few underdogs of course
we have mr beast paired up against
ludwig who's here playing for his third
time he's been training so many days we
have box box who went very close to the
finals um also previously beat ludwig
playing justin minx she's been learning
chess for about two months but she's
working working really hard fondy he's
been playing he already played two chess
tournaments actually three counting
twitch rivals so a lot of experienced
players today uh do you think there's
gonna be any upsets today anna
i'm hoping so i'm hoping so even though
justin ming's our our mutual friend
justin has tweeted that she thinks she's
gonna go down but she will go down by
supporting her own charity initiative
she's saying that every loss she will
donate a hundred dollars and for every
blunder he she is donating ten dollars
and if she wins by checkmate she's
donating a thousand so there's a lot on
the line when it comes to charity
initiatives and minx has made her own
game apart from the one that will be for
the result it's also for charity i hope
she gets that checkmate
i hope soti i hope so too huge thanks
obviously to our sponsor coinbase uh
book champs for is presented by coinbase
and whether you are looking to make your
first crypto purchase or if you are
already an experienced trader do check
out coinbase and this is uh this time
the url coinbase.com
chess if you want to go over and get a
five dollar
bitcoin uh account well you own your
account five dollars worth of bitcoin
for free i love free stuff andra i don't
know how you think about it but if you
register and you get that five dollar in
bitcoin to me that sounds like a great
deal yeah you hold it for a couple years
and it's gonna triple don't but don't
this is not financial advice especially
from a 19 year old i love your financial
advices i remember one video where you
were basically describing it as docs on
a rooftop if i recall it correctly but
we also have apart from our financial
advice the coinbase community cup
if you think you've got what it takes to
be a product champ yourself you can
participate in coinbase community cup
which is taking place every single day
of our pog champs for competition
for awesome prices you just need to make
sure to join by using the command
exclamation mark coinbase cop and
there's more information about the
tournament in the chat plus do join the
community cup
oh and we are back i thought for a
second i lost you andre we were going
into the house so confused i was so
confused i thought i lost you for a
second but we did not lose our
participants we do see both fundy and
techstone already streaming ready for
the battle speaking of chaitis fondue
himself has created a separate charity
initiative i believe he is donating
every donation and subscription of his
stream of today to cancer research as
well the charity by uh that he will be
supporting on his own initiative but
remember that
which whichever
community whichever initiative you want
to support we have our own one here as
well every single charity is worth your
support and we hope that you will enjoy
today's show of course on that note
shall we take a quick break andrea and
tune in with techtone pre-match a bit of
pretty much hype by the streamer let's
do it
did i see who
you saw tomorrow no why where would i
say tomah
[Music]
are you telling me that i can't beat
random players in 200 mmr bullet three
minute chess and that means i can't beat
somebody who's over 1 000 rating in all
forms of chess
interesting
i beg to differ
i
i think i'm gonna be fine
quiet
tomah
why are you all [__] talking about
is totally gonna be a five star this is
the most four-star looking [__]
i've ever seen in my life
is he a dog
wait oh no wait trending
hold on it's not trending trending a day
off twitch what is this
just a reminder please do not stream or
view streams on september 1st
many creators can't sacrifice more than
this we need twitch in their ad before
yeah but that's like 2.1 release date
can we push it back a day i didn't agree
to that day
i didn't agree that's 2.1
that that's like i've been looking
forward to streaming this day for
[__] 12 weeks yo did you see they are
adding a pay-to-win glider and name card
to the whale shop so i like here i'll
tell you what
i'll take off the second
all right
unless that way is there 30 months
oh that's the first
yeah but the first is like the day after
2.1
you know and that's a pretty good day
too
uh
oh my schedule's kind of my schedule's
kind of tight
oh my schedule so what what big
streamers are doing that
do they get like do they get like uh xqc
is xqc taking a day off
or who who what big names are taking the
day off
no one not a single big streamer
asthma wouldn't either
no one stopping streaming
oh
i'm pretty sure i got a chess match on
that date too so i don't think i can
just call it off
so
as unlucky
it just it doesn't fit my schedule we
can reschedule we'll talk
we'll talk and a lot we'll fix that
bottom
oh wait winning fundy's title is called
winning pog champs four
white actually
my head is full of caffeine if i go left
and right you can hear like slushing
around like a slush puppy
i hope this dude isn't stressed out
because i'm an idiot
hold on i got you
funders
hey i'm holding this you're not nervous
yes because i'm an idiot
congrats on the dust
oh i think this is it i can't type that
message
what
what did i say
what oh my god
what did i even say that was wrong
[Music]
what
are you kidding me okay funny
go ahead collect your w
dude nobody nobody will expect the insta
forfeit what a twist
you know what a twist what a master
don't even move i surrender
no we'll see you know the hippo it's
pretty good
every single match i've lost today is
because of time
but now i'm going into a match where all
i have is time
you know judging by fundy here's my game
plan judging by fundy he's probably
going to think that i'm an absolute
[__] buffoon
and to his point he's right but here's
the thing
he's gonna go for an aggressive play
early he'll probably kings kings bandit
what do you think will it be doctor who
offsets today's match or the
uh favorite of group c fundi will win
the match easier you can tell us more
about your predictions on the discord
this is all the social media platforms
where you can join us but on discord
particularly we have a blockchains for
group and our sponsor coinbase will be
giving out diamond memberships during
the tournament to members of the
pogchamps channel so if you don't want
to miss out on this chance and the
discussion over at discord make sure to
use exclamation mark contest in the chat
and join for a chance of winning a
diamond membership
let's take a look at the format of the
event andrea this is one of those
exciting
match formats where we have the players
playing two games one with each color
the players are already split into
groups we have 16 amazing streamers
gamers content creators split into four
groups everyone plays everyone in the
group stage and this is three points for
a win outright two if it's a win in thai
breaks and one if you tied originally
but then there is a blitz tiebreaker
so far the matches didn't need a tie
break or maybe today will be one of
those days when we get to see a third
blitz tiebreaker a 10 plus a 10 plus
five second time control is the original
time control so the first two games are
ten minutes with a five second increment
and if you need a tiebreaker that will
be a three minute blitz game the top two
players advance to the championship
bracket of each group and the bottom two
will go to the consolation bracket
andre if we take a look at today's
pairings starting with the match between
fundi and techtone we have the highest
rated player in group c fundi taking on
the lowest rated player of the very same
group does this mean this will be a very
one-sided match or do you think there
will be upsets maybe in this very first
game
i mean i was listening to techtone's
stream a little bit he was already
trying to predict fundy's play i feel
like techtone you know he's he's very
well prepared he was making up chess
openings that fundy might be playing so
nothing could go wrong of course i'm a
little biased i did do many chess
lessons with fundy but i would love to
see some tiebreakers today what do you
think anna how do you think tech john
will do
i think he has a really difficult
opponent i believe fondly could be one
of the favorites for the overall
championship he did manage to beat even
ludwig at the block battles hosted by
you two obviously the amazing boat and
sisters i was watching i loved the show
of blog battles finished just a week or
so ago but andrea you did mention um the
lessons with fondi did you look at any
particular openings one e4 is already on
the board
yeah we we studied the ponziani a little
bit um but let's see what tech tone is
going to reply with i have a feeling
that fundy is not going to be using that
theory and i'm right but b6 is a very
solid move especially for beginners it's
just like a new account very solid move
indeed let's listen a bit fondly what
does he think oh boy okay um well
let's think about everything so he's
gonna put his bishop there to attack
this
which means i don't really care about it
i'm just going to take control of the
center and get my knights out get my
bishops out get a nice pattern castle
right
i think that's quite all right so this
is not being attacked
if this it gets double tanked so might
as well do
this first
and then if this happens we do that
so we attack or we we defend
right
that's a very sound center bender you
must be proud of your students wow
already
this is really
he had the right idea about the wrong
move order
yeah i think he was a little bit too
stressed out he was really thinking
about his principles i don't really care
if this gets hit because we'll just take
with this and we still have control over
the center
oh and the capture indeed happened on
that tree
i don't know
let's see oh this is a techno okay
he did spotted and moved to c6
he's defending very well for his level
so what's he's the first player do we
just go here and then castle
i think so
that is a great idea and even though
fondly lost that central pawn he's up
and ahead in development and that's
important to take the initiative and
compensate for the material down so i
think his position is actually looking
really good tactile still needs to
develop all his pieces now that bishop
finally made it to g7 oh interesting so
tekton looks like he's maybe trying to
bring his knight to e7 instead of to f6
but like what you said fundy is a lot
better developed he's already castled
they're taking out his knight and his
bishops so even though he's down that
pawn i think he's going to get the
attack early on
i agree with you and uh tacton has spent
quite some time on the pawn pushes which
means that the minor pieces as well as
the king is still on the original square
i wonder if one is considering knight to
e4 to try to exploit the weakness of the
d6 square and the fact that the king yes
he is playing it
oh no
go there dead go there
i don't think he knows i don't think
he's aware he just realized that wasn't
good
is that what you want you want to check
my cake well i guess so
and the king has indeed been checked
and more is coming but why would you
check my king
what do you get from contact don't see
now the checkmate i'm pretty sure fundy
sees it
you don't really get anything
yeah
okay i guess you're there now i guess
just now realized
[Music]
oh
oh god that's pretty good
okay no that's a good play
no that's that's pretty good that's so
pretty
that's pretty good
okay all right fundy
well that was a faster game than what we
expected it is true that fondy is the
heavy favorite here but the checkmate in
only 11 moves after dropping the central
pawn
that was impressive for the record we're
making an improvement from pogchamps one
we did have like a six move checkmate
with voice and xqc so at least the
participants slowly are getting longer
games you know step by step
very true very true but this will mean
that uh now we are shortly heading to
game two the players will have a bit of
a breaker it felt like the game itself
was shorter than our breaks but tactile
will now have the white pieces and let's
listen in with him while we take a quick
break on if he has any plans what will
be his strategy for this second game to
make a comeback
thank you so much for the raid thank you
so much
thank you so much
i appreciate that thank you thank you
thank you uh so what we're doing is
we're luring him
into a false sense of security
right you see
you see
it's like let me explain let me explain
what this is
let me explain what this is so you know
when like
you know when like
like when raditz kidnapped gohan
and like killed his dad
right
i'm gohan
right so give me like two more seasons
give me like two more seasons
and i'm gonna go into the hyperbolic
time chamber
and i'll be like super saiyan 2 until
the riots in japan happen and they say
what goku is the best character
[__]
[Music]
fundy sent me a message
and he says i was so confused
i'm sorry
oh jesus christ
do me a favor
next round
on the fifth
move
blunder your queen so it's a fair fight
oh we got this oh we got this watch this
[__] we're gonna be good
we're gonna be good
oh we can do this hey i ain't no coward
i ain't no [__]
but i won't bring it back we'll run a
bag
hey we'll run it back
we'll run it back we'll be good we'll be
okay first time a chat hi hello what a
pleasure it is to have you
you know
he'll consider it let's go
[Music]
let's go dad let's go
okay
yo we better get clapton fundy won't
even have a queen oh come on bro
okay so i'm stupid where is this
oh
netherlands
is that where the undertaker's from
netherlands so like parts unknown
[Music]
netherlands
welcome back to our pog champs for
coverage presented by coinbase that has
been quite some off game
action on discord tacked on trying to
convince fundy to blunder his queen and
he also messaged fondue saying yo bro my
mom is watching you can't do me like
that
i would honestly love to see a bow test
gambit but i feel like fundy is gonna
have no mercy
i think so too he's so focused he so
wants to do well in this event overall
not just in his group but i feel like he
really is motivated to try to win the
championship bracket but this will be an
interesting
rematch now attacked on with the white
pieces possibly going for the same setup
the hippo but this time hoping to make
it to the castle and not have his king
checkmated didn't move 11.
yeah you know maybe fundy will have some
fun he could throw in a bomb cloud oh
and the game has started
all right let's see if uh techtone is
gonna try to be a little bit more
cautious this game but
debating based on his uh negotiations i
don't think that's the plan
he really wants the queen but i don't
think fondly will eventually give up the
queen he said he will oh consider it on
cloud maybe
do you think fondly would play the bone
cloud he's going for the classical
development of the knight and tactone
trying to set up that
famous hippopotamus is protected
it is indeed very solid somehow is it
gonna is this gonna happen
yes
funny i think that's the answer you're
predicting it correctly that's what
tectum wants to do
what is happening i don't fully get it
look at his nice symmetry oh he is going
to do this
right if this happens beautiful that's
being attacked but not really
for those of you
who don't worry it's not one of the most
common openings it's a very rare opening
but it's it's one of these uh very solid
setups white is not being very
aggressive
i kind of just want to take as much
center as possible before he does any of
this
um
looks like very similar to the opening
in the first game
in the center
very true but so far he hasn't dropped
the pawn maybe he wishes because that
gave him quite the future in the
previous game it is protected
once again
and he's going to do that and this is
also protected i guess
if i were to do this this this this this
hold on
he takes itec he takes itech he takes
yeah he's up
what's the plan
let's see what planned funding will come
up get i want to get this nice position
very nicely set up i want to get this
not in a better position so i can start
pushing that i would also like to hear
tech tones guide and see what his plan
let's tune in with his stream as well
indeed and how confident he's about his
hippopotamus okay yeah you do your thing
well you don't realize i'm impregnable
okay
i'm pregnant
i guess those two things are the same
oh
[Music]
move that up i will clap your [__]
cheek son
you don't want this
okay
boom
you don't want to do that
you blundered your pawn i appreciate
that
[Music]
should i be scared
my number one advice would be terrifying
you'll take my horse
to castle first
but he's not doing it
indeed castle as soon as you can before
he trades with his pawn
right
oh [__] are you gonna try to [__]
take my queen you psychopath
you wouldn't dare
you would not dare
let's see if when it takes a bishop for
pawn he chooses the bishop to offer a
trade
it is pretty right though because now
the light squares around the king of
texas are weak
without your pawns here but
what does that really do
whoa
there we go a castle finally should i
have taken that
well now then i lose my queen
good point excellent it's better that
you did not take it costly was the right
choice
i'm just afraid that from this knight
will end up going to f3 it's knight e5
knight f3 and then maybe we'll see a
checkmate on h2 for now i believe that
if knight t5 happens trying to exploit
the the weakness of the light squares
bishop takes e5 would have been a good
move so fondly goes for bishop to e5
making sure that the knight cannot be
captured but this allows a queen trade
andra will we see what we are i believe
seeing
uh the trade of the queens luckily for
tactile that makes the king feel safer
if there's yeah
queen's off the board much lower chances
that he's gonna get get checkmated very
early on and i do like he predicted his
night plan right away trying to get that
outpost night which is gonna be very
annoying um i think fundy is definitely
a little bit more experienced in the end
game and when you're the higher rated
player that's kind of the easiest way to
go about it and just trade pieces and go
straight into the end game
very true especially with such a
beautiful location for the knights so
what we were highlighting earlier with
the trade of the bishops that the g2
bishop was controlling the light squares
ooh
that now the bishop is no longer on the
board and f4 would be a great move if it
could not be taken ampassan does tecton
know
the rules of ample sound did he expect
let's tune in if we could
well [__] that
uh
well [__]
i think he knew he just didn't i thought
that [__] was disabled in the tournament
that's a technicality oh never mind
oh
[__] technicality how the [__] was i
pokemon that the forbidden move was
allowed in this tournament
this always happens every chess
tournament
oh i thought that wasn't allowed [__]
well
now look at me i look like a [__]
fool
next time we'll have to disable it anna
i guess so
it's interesting how it keeps catching
the players off guard even if they know
about the ampersand rule obviously this
is a very
specific capture at chess
and it seems that tactone is aware of
ampa sombo thought that maybe it wasn't
allowed during the event the rules for
the tournament in terms of chess are the
exact same rules that everyone else
plays with including the rochester
champion magnus clause and hikaruna
cameron the rest of the top grand master
so our park champs participants are
playing with the exact same rules look
he's just waiting for the new patch of
chess where you can disable certain
rules like no castling no imposant it's
coming he's just predicting the future
possibly chess 2.0 is knocking on the
door decked on writing his own rules i
like the suggestion if there was
one feature you can disable would you
not allow costly would you not allow um
an ampersand capture um this is
something to think about for the future
of chess
well there's not sadly there's not much
else we could disable because there's
only so much fun in chess
of different rules
indeed now fun day with up
this healthy extra pawn on f3 also plays
a really strong rook to d2 the rook is
doing a great job attacking now the
entire second rank the c2 pawn hanging
but also looking toward the king's side
in case there can be in the future an
attack against the white king yep end
game principles always coming in taking
that second rank he could even maybe
come later with the knight g4 trying to
attack here it's a very comfortable
position for black
indeed it is very difficult now for
tekton to try to do something i like his
choice of offering a rook trade because
the rook of black on d2 is extremely
strong you need to try to
capture or at least exchange
the best pieces of your opponent and
that's what he's doing
yeah let's see how well of course you
know if black takes here white doesn't
necessarily have to worry for much
longer about these hanging pawns but
maybe he's going to double oh he didn't
double the rooks okay
so this is
playing up he's defending quite well
here but he is defending very well but
fondly comes with another strong move
and ready to replace the rook that was
traded for another recruit it's a great
move no matter where he goes i'm going
to win a pawn
you can't defend it you can't go here
either because the pawn is protecting
that
you can go back there
that's the only one that's a bit
annoying if it goes back here
bundy continues to be very focused
during the game
but then i can do this and get my pawn
in
techtone not so much but
it is a tough matchup for tekton and
fondy indeed
is in the zone he didn't even play that
knight check before that would have
dropped his pawn i just have this right
he's got the right idea he's just double
checking if the rook is safe on d2
so he can go here
no defense
just remember he can do he can do
checkmate he can he can do that and
that's checkmate right
good point that he could he's a 500
right go for that i take opponent
seriously all right i take opponent
seriously yeah
he really does he's even looking out for
his threats still
he is looking out for every possible
threat and he pointed out the biggest
threat that white could create if the
black crook abandons the d file whiter
going to d1 would mean rook d8 a back
rank checkmate threat already sees it
before his rook even left the d file i
know he's giving him no chances to even
try to sneak a win there
very impressive play by fondly i think
now he will capture the pawn on h2 or
consider to delay it if he's worried
about that background checkmate thread
but after rook d1 he still has time to
prevent the checkmate yeah i have a
feeling he'll probably just take the
pawn go for a g6 build an escape square
um we could also listen and detect and
see how he's holding up if he's staying
optimistic here what this plan is
tell me after he drank that rotten milk
in episode one
oh my god i would give you a piece of my
mind
i will give you a i would give you a
piece of my mind fondy i swear
and opponent is captured indeed that
don't replay what has just happened
he's always in disbelief with the pawns
being captured
what the [__]
yo [__] this take my horse
ooh
there's a bigger thread that rook check
on age one is very strong especially
after the trailer tonight
shall we bring our analysis board back
real quick because that was a mischance
by funding he's still of course doing
extremely well but he could have been up
a rook
he could have been up for rook if he had
spotted the check on age one the king
has to move up to the second rank and
then black is able to capture that free
rook on c1 so he did see if they did see
that the pawn was hanging he defended
against it but he didn't see that he had
something even better i think tekton saw
a move later which he was lucky because
both players missed it
he's still hanging in there i like this
he's trying to be tricky but fundy did
already spot this back rank earlier in
the game so i don't think he's going to
fall for it now
yeah it seems that maybe tactile
suspected after d5 now with the record
a2 there is no longer a back rank check
winning the rook d5 is so tricky indeed
because of the background checkmate that
fondy predicted that that could be a
threat for white so the pawn cannot be
taken on d5 because then rook state is
checkmate and if it cannot be taken it
means that white will manage to push it
all the way to d6 or take on c6
chad is saying that he saw rook h1 but
didn't like it but
uh looks like he's going back for it
oh and now he wants to set it back and
try it
it might be it oh it's not late actually
because uh
dakton goes for d6 that is a strong pass
pawn but the rook is still stronger than
a passport and fondly has time to
capture the rook and then control the
past pawn
so we could maybe look at that line for
how could black win the rook and stop
the white pawn anna
let's take a look at it indeed andrea
rook even check well we have a play down
on board maybe
rook age one czech is the way to win the
rook fund he spotted it now third time
charm takes the rook and he's just in
time to catch the pawn after pawn to d7
right he's about to promote now you can
come to d1 and stop it we didn't even
have to show the chat fundy played
perfectly here
let's tune in with him and see what he
thinks now that the pawn is no longer a
danger
chad's turning
arson
[Music]
um i think i'm happy with this right i'm
literally i'm literally up eight pieces
you can win okay
night
you'll win this
it's like a reverse back ring so now
you're an animal abuser huh
wow so now you're an animal abuser wow
big man fundy yeah your true colors show
tonight
you know what i'm going to make your ass
stale mate me
hey ain't going to know what to do
i like his spirit he has the fighting
back up kid yeah that's right rotten
yeah that's right
i'm gonna beat your ass when i get up
there i'm going to beat your ass
a little bit physical for chess did you
wait no no no no no no don't either you
didn't even turn into a horse so what
type of man are you really
coward
respected into copies promotion to a
knight yeah he's just not returning the
favors
they're actually olympic athletes it's
actually a [__] queen
oh
was that a mouse slip
i mean even dow dropping the queen fund
is still [__] that's tuned in but
funding wasn't because he wanted me to
sacrifice the queen
there it is it was not a move five it
was a move 40 but whatever
he did
he did it i did what he did it would
have been nice if we got a little
earlier but he did uh promise his end of
the deal
true sorry i'm back with numbers i have
dyslexia
i'm sorry oh well almost the same
blundering your queen or move five or
more 40 but of course fondly knows that
he can afford it because he's still
winning he's up the rook and he's gonna
get a new queen
next time you propose a deal with your
opponent make sure you specify what move
yes i think texting was aiming for move
five but fondly um
actually agreed to that part of the deal
techtone is still clinging on for that
stalemate but
[Music]
it could still be still made indeed
there's only one square for the king i
can't move
here
here the funniest way to focus the cell
mate
here
and now there's a checkmate opportunity
indeed queen to g5 and an applause from
texas and this has been
a very nicely played game from start to
finish
for the queen plunder
let's go
all right hey close
that was close we had them on the ropes
we did have him on the ropes tacticon is
saying well it wasn't as close of a game
as we hoped for but because every single
day we do have the play of the game as
well we will give it over to you guys
soon on deciding what do you think were
some of the best moments of this
previous match and make sure to do so
for the upcoming matches too this is the
eternal play of the game all you need to
do is sign up at eternal dot gg connect
it to your twitch account and then you
can use the command in the chat this
will go for collectibles digital
collectibles that will be released on
september the 12th and all the
proceeds from the purchases will go to
our charity red as well making mental
health accessible to tens of thousands
of people there will be three lucky
winners per match so make sure to use uh
your voting in the chat all you need to
do is type in eternal during the matches
in whichever moment you think this
moment deserves to become a digital
collective or make sure to type in
eternal in the chat that's all you need
to do you can type it in as many times
as you want to make your vote count but
first you need to sign up at eternal.gg
connect it to your twitch account and
then you can use the vote function and
get those free collectibles if you are
one of the winners
with that andrea we have had our first
match finished in 2-0 in favor of the
highest rated player of group c fundi
the match unfortunately finished a lot
faster than we expected i wonder if we
could talk to the players we will figure
it out soon yeah if they can join us
because it would be it would be great to
talk to them and see how that banter
went in between the games than just
their thoughts on the action
i would love to interview him as well
but for the record i mean techtone
played very well for a 500 which is
on the second game mainly at that level
you're blundering so much and he's
paired against funny who like you said
one of the highest rated i predict that
fundy will be going to the championship
match maybe head to head with luddit wig
which you said even previously beat it
was with time odds so this is one of our
strongest competitors and tech tunes
still did very well for a beginner here
very true and we did see a botus gambit
as well i think andrea that was
particularly dedicated to you too
obviously
um it was it was suggested by tekto and
maybe the move number um was gonna be a
bit earlier according to tact when he
was expecting a queen blunder move five
funded did eventually play the queen
sacrifice on about move 40. yeah it
wouldn't be pogchamps without a botezz
gambit i see we have one of our next
competitors who are also already
practicing maybe we could take a look at
box box preparations for the second
match of today with minx and box box
own streaming history while supporting
your favorite gamers and streamers by
buying their digital collectibles on
eternal
collecting these sometimes hilarious
always epic gaming and irl highlights
directly benefits the creators while
providing you the fans something unique
and special to keep
sign up on eternal.gg build your own
collection and feel the thrill of
ripping digital packs and viewing
amazing moments in the marketplace
[Music]
did they finish the game
oh they finished
wait they're gonna watch me watch them
oh this that's really awkward
oh
wow that that's unfortunate timing okay
anyway
i believe our match should be starting
soon so we'll just do puzzles until then
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
what is it tell me
what
[Music]
oh i see it sets up for this threat
i see i see
[Music]
this is the play
and we are joined by the players funding
techton what a match this has been and
the banter in between games from the
congratulations and tech tone as andrea
informed you while we were setting up
this interview you are now the second
player in the history of blockchains for
to go for these short games after sqc i
think to be on the podium that is
something that's an accomplishment
yeah i mean uh the the bulgarian
somersault is a high risk high reward uh
play style but i went for it
unfortunately um
the sun was in my eyes so i i blundered
a little bit but uh next time um
i'm hoping to pull off the uh the
russian knee sock and maybe we'll get a
w but i tried my best i played the best
game just like good but uh fundy was the
better man
today fondy did you spot it immediately
that you had this chance with the knight
check the checkmate i was i i blundered
a pawn and i didn't know what to do i
just i just started putting my pieces
somewhere and at some point i thought i
saw a checkmate
but i genuinely was like a minute
staring at my screen like is this
actually happening like am i really sure
that this is happening right now
because you know the second second
fastest game in in in history now tech
jones you're welcome by the way i gave
you this
i hope you're proud well we gave you it
to us you're up there silver
you know i uh you know i like to give
handouts you know i figured you know
funny could use a bone so
no i had no idea i had no i had none i
was like yeah you may have seen
checkmate i didn't i had no idea at all
i learned i learned this uh this opener
called the hippo from the jt he's a
really good really good buddy of mine
tommy chess and the hippo to me i
thought was an impenetrable defense well
today it got penetrated and that was not
good dude that sucked that sucks
are you gonna continue to play the hippo
now
oh yeah i mean i made a promise to jt
it's like you know master i look like
master roshi goku and krillin i'm like
i'm like his i'm like his son like i'm
in the turtle squad i'm in the hippo
squad i'm attempting to take the hippo
as far as possible but unfortunately
today i didn't do it justice but soon
the hippo will rise again
the hippo will rise again i respect that
man i respect that thank you speaking of
the turtle squad funny i think you're
wearing your third t-shirt is that
correct i am there's a little green
t-shirt you're right
i don't know how you knew that but
you're right
we're spying on you
but i i just wanted to i wanted to
compliment the outfits for today the
turtle t-shirt and your shirt tactone
i've recently started playing pokemon so
i was just like staring at that shirt
the whole time yeah it's really nice
thank you where did you get it can you
please send me a link uh so my wife just
buys me all my clothes i don't know
i have to contact her in that case yeah
go for it
honestly this was such a fun match we
were hoping it would be a bit
longer
but nevertheless it was really exciting
rubbing it in there a little bit anna
yeah
so sorry
yeah no because what you don't realize
is like if if fundy didn't notice that i
was gonna win the next turn
trust you'll see if you re-watch the
footage i was one play-off i would have
checked my hundred percent i feel like
that sounds legit could be true i there
was a mate coming around the corner
i thought on passant wasn't allowed and
then you aren't personally dude what do
you mean it's not allowed well i thought
it was disabled i didn't know i just
thought are you disabling literally a
rolling chest
okay back down that's the next patch of
chess we haven't gotten to it yet
disabling that okay that's next patch
we're a little bit behind
that's not
all right yeah man
i'm telling you funny i saw it somewhere
it was somewhere in the patch notes okay
patch nuts the yeah the passionates of
chess
that's been there for like 700 years
yeah the patch notes you'll see and
pause games five dude i'm telling you
it's gonna they're gonna implement on
basant
disabled you did give us an idea though
because this one this just has been
around for a few years by now but maybe
chess 2.0 is scared to come for the
future of it disabling maybe costly
disabling on poisson we'll need some
feedback on that from you guys because i
think that's a great idea you could
disable if i can add if i can add like
interesting ideas into the patch notes i
i would like uh like a king sacrifice
that'd be cool to be able to do that
oh well maybe make the king a
non-garbage unit
why like why am i protecting this lazy
bastard like he doesn't even do anything
he is he is pretty useless
some amazing ideas there i think with
you guys we could work on that chess 2.0
it's time i think for chess to get an
update but in the meantime we truly
enjoyed your match and we hope the best
for both of you thank you so much for
joining us for the interview great
outfits great moves and all the best for
the remaining matches in group c
thank you thank you okay
andrea this has been such a fun
potential update for the future of chess
but also for the future of everyone
in our community this is another call to
action that we are raising funds for
rise above the disorder that is our
official charity they have already
helped tens of thousands of people to
receive mental health care for free and
if you want to support their initiative
all you need to do is go to our url
go.chess.com
and donate chess.com is matching every
donation up to a hundred thousand
dollars so it's high time to use your
initiative move on not just the chess
board but in the world to help those who
may need it in terms of mental health
care
and on that note andrea i think it's
time for us to take a quick break so
that we can get our next players ready
for the show box box and just the minks
that match is coming up next very soon
i'm so excited for this one forming
she's been so nervous but i think it's
gonna be one of the most entertaining
matches of the week
it is going to be fun and the reminder
that minx has tweeted about the match
and how much she's going to donate for
charity for each blunder for each loss
or a checkmate in case she manages to
checkmate her opponent let's go for a
quick break to get the players ready and
we also have a video prepared for you
guys i believe
hey y'all my name is techtone and today
i really want to talk about something
very important and that is each and
every one of you out there matters and i
find it an absolute travesty where there
are people who think that with their
issues they have to be alone because you
don't you do not have to be alone there
are always people out there who are
willing to help especially with the
people that rise above the disorder aka
rad
now i can tell you this right now
i am no perfect human being
i have been through the humps and the
trials and the tribulations and
everything that held me down to thinking
techtone you're not good enough you
don't deserve help you don't deserve
anybody giving you a helping hand well
the thing is is that those are the
things that are going to plague your
mind until you can realize and i'm
letting you know once again that you
matter and if you need help you can get
it and if you know somebody else who
needs help they can get it too we are
going to be raising enough money to get
a hundred thousand therapy sessions for
anybody who needs it
with every 30 donation someone out there
can get a week's worth of therapy for
free and that can be the change that can
be the root cause of changing somebody's
negativity in their life beginning anew
and finally getting some much needed
positivity
[Music]
down
you asking me to strip
i want to get this over with so i can
take my l and cry
oops i almost broke my desk
uh okay i'll sing again
[Music]
i'm not gonna throw it back
i can't throw it back
like i said i'm like plank from ed and
eddie
i throw back my bones creak
g-fuel chat drink it
you're on chess stream no i'm not
because they didn't invite me yet
they said they'll be in touch soon
i don't want you on your tricksters
there is no passion there is no vision
there is no aggression there is no
[__] mind
oh wow i'm on it
hey everybody
hello everybody i'm both streams
i've seen my competition might be a tad
bit stronger than i am
no stress here
no stress
we're fine
can my competition do a wheelie though
i think not
yep
nope you might be got a chest but can i
do a wheelie
nope
so overall
so overall i think it's important that
it's okay to take an l sometimes it's
inspirational
that was miss justin minx who is about
to start her first ever pogchamps game
but before we get to see the first moves
let's take a look at what is at stake
andrea the price fund for pogchamps four
a hundred thousand dollars in total with
twenty thousand going to the winner
second place is twelve thousand that is
in each bracket uh after the group stage
as we already mentioned the top two will
go to the championship bracket the
bottom two to the consolation bracket so
there's there's a lot to play for in
both brackets and a hundred thousand
dollars in total at stake
there's a huge prize fund and they're
also simultaneously raising money for
charity even our own contestants today
are gonna be donating based on their
plays as we could see we had the
contrast of the preparation box box
doing 1900 rated puzzles minx doing mind
chess from her wheelchair i don't know
how else to describe it um i think minx
is very well prepared what do you think
anna
she's very well prepared she took a
lesson both with you and me just a few
days and weeks ago so i think she's more
than ready but it is a tough match for
her this is her first ever pogchamps
participation box box played in the very
first edition of focus and he's
returning to play again obviously much
higher rated than minx but these are the
opportunities where a lower rated player
or in this case in mix's case a beginner
she can improve a lot from games like
this and let's not forget that after the
group stage the brackets that's when the
real deal begins the knockout phase so i
think if minx uses these battles for
improving further and she can do well in
the constellation bracket yeah i totally
agree she's been very motivated to study
um we still have yet to beat the 400
rated chess.com bot but as soon as she
does that she's gonna go crush the next
bracket
indeed that was in her tweet as well as
we already referred to
her tweeting earlier that she's 250
rated and haven't even won
against a beginner but that's minx on
twitter but she is using this occasion
to do her own charity initiative for
every loss she's going to donate a
hundred dollars for every blunder she's
donating on top of it the ten dollars
per dollar and she's adding to it that
she usually blunders about 20 times
during the game so lots of charity
occasions but we are hoping that she
will go for the biggest steak that she
has tweeted out if she wins with a
checkmate it's a thousand dollars for
charity yeah maybe we could let boxbox
know you know for the kids that if
somehow he walks into a checkmate one
thousand dollars would be donated to
charity
yes i think he he should take that into
consideration let's listen and if that's
something that is on his mind or what is
his pre-match preparation like apart
from the puzzles
[Music]
xbox always has the best music
it's really good vibes indeed
[Music]
i think he's just being informed about
the start of the game so he's just
messaging our team back all right all
right
it's time for the chess match uh so just
you guys know we'll be playing a set
it's the best of two against just the
minks uh i believe it's ten plus five
time format
and i have to put my chat in emo only
mode
and i will not be looking at my chat
no no helpers i gotta do this on my own
guys i'm sorry i gotta fight my own
fight
no helpers indeed how is minx preparing
for the start of the game
no
do i seem nervous to you chat
do i seem nervous to you i got the
shakes i'm not gonna lie i saw this [__]
earlier i'm kidding i'm kidding i just
saw myself pop off one chest as i said
that
every time
it's okay it's timing for me
i don't even want to read their chat
right now i'm embarrassed i'm just
looking the other way
turning the cheek yeah don't look turn
in the cheek
do not have the best timing boys no i do
not
want to take a peek over now oh
up few little w's do you guys hear what
i said
no we didn't hear any no
never happened don't worry i saw the box
box was on the screen so i was just
having an intimate moment with my chat
thingy i made it rain i can't believe
let that cancer into the metaphorical
balls
yes
i can't believe that you really voted
1.5 million against 14 000 like i get it
right i would do the same
but i thought a few few people would be
like
i i don't even want to know that ratio
well i can't count
do you believe um fun facts about me let
me smash
all right
found that out yesterday because of
epilepsy
it's a real thing
so you're not allowed to make fun of me
here guys i'll be like yeah
what's your tone what's your phone now
what's your tone underscore kid as well
thank god my child made me find that out
it's true
all right well that is minx's pregame
preparation
chat i think everyone here has their
money on minks it's going to be a huge
upset the underdog i'm going to cheer
her on what do you think anna
she deserves to reach here though she's
a friend of both andre and me obviously
but box box is the more experienced
player as we already highlighted he
played in the very first pogchamps event
last year and he has been training
since back and forth with puzzles
training games and he goes for the very
classical pawn to e4
all right minx is just following him i
like it so far can't go wrong at all we
have that 1000 rating point difference
1000 rating point difference but so far
minx is following our lead what we
taught her about development the bishop
also is out and she's ready to castle
well i don't know what you taught her i
tried to show her checkmate did you
teach her about development
i did and she told me that she also had
she still remembered some of the lessons
that she took a year ago
with you ladies so i'm sure that that's
all in there in the back of her mind
even if she's bouncing up and down on
that wheelchair that she has in her room
i don't even know how she got the
wheelchair but it's part of her studio
yeah you just don't ask questions about
minx's background ever she lives in a
morgue so i learned i just don't ask
questions
not there's questions about this pompous
either i don't know andrea boxbox is the
higher rated player but h3 is a very
cautious move maybe it wasn't needed
perhaps he wants to place the bishop on
e3 and he didn't like knight to g4 and
it seems mink's oh wow oh no
not just cautious he goes for aggression
oh makes his mouse slip she wanted to
castle oh no let's tune in with minx
[Music]
he does not react
he freaked me out with whatever he did
there
[Music]
hey she won a pawn
she did
maybe this is working out that she
didn't castle so that king i believe was
gonna go to g8 but instead it was
dropped on f8 see she couldn't cast so
that way but now she's up a pawn because
bob's box went for this pawn push to f4
not realizing that both of the pawns of
minx on e5 and g5 are looking at that
square this actually worked out
perfectly for her because now she has a
rook sniping in the file of the king she
just opened it up she just gained a pawn
she has a strong pawn chain which is
locking in this dark squared bishop it's
actually a great position for black i
don't know how it happened but minx is
has a little bit of an advantage here
everything worked out well for her ever
since that mouse slip she is up upon the
evaluation but is happily showing an
advantage for black that's what you guys
can see to the left of the board we have
the evaluation button it is showing the
the current situation black having an
advantage even that rook on g8 is
perfectly placed now that that is an
open file semi-open for black it's
really not an easy position for white to
play uh we could check out what box box
is planning here
oh wait
no let's do this one
he's trying to undermine the phone
structure that's supporting the f4 pawn
that makes perfect sense mink's
developing very well for her level
[Music]
okay i'm just going to open up the game
we have two very different choices of
music
open up the game simplify it down
[Music]
no
everything is going so well
box box is so puzzled because it was
gonna be a queen trade but minx forgot
to take the queen back she stepped out
of the check
[Music]
everything was going so well
more music i love that she's continuing
the game as if nothing happened
you're a bit disney
[Music]
she continues her development everything
would be perfect if she took the queen
back so that queen of white is not
supposed to be on the board
all right i think we could go back to
the analysis board my ears are bleeding
just a little bit well what can i say
cutie cinderella did an alex bottas
impression yesterday but i think minx
takes the cake today for both as
impressions
true very true she was in a check with
that queen capture if we go back to that
moment real quick to show
that it was supposed to be a queen trade
box box obviously knew that it can be
taken either with the bishop or the
knight um but mink spotted the check and
moved the king
yep that was very interesting play i
think she's just very committed to the
bit as we know minx is a master role
player and i think she and kitty
cinderella are just having a contest
exactly
this is all about team envy the squad is
here with the butter sisters and means
wanting to be now the third sister yeah
i was i was so proud of her development
was perfect um like you said she
continued to develop but now she's just
down so many pieces uh it's very hard to
hold this position as black
yeah but each and every blunder of hers
counts for her charity initiative so in
that sense
and you are right andra that it will add
up for a good cause
yeah she's actively raising money for
the kids as we speak as that night drops
off the board and maybe another one
let's see if she spots this
she does all right
no more charity there now she's coming
for his rook
she's coming for the box box should move
it there's only one square for that rook
on b1 and box box 2 could go for the
botus gambit if he for instance wants to
give a check on f6 with the queen and
not noticing the knight that's sneakily
guarding that square let's listen him
with box box and what he thinks
yeah that rock's not gonna be useful for
a long time so just invite the inviter
take it and go here
sacrificing the rook on purpose
strategic and then she's probably gonna
worry about the night
okay and then i go boom
[Music]
right and now that i finally open up
that key space i can go here
i can push in it's like a chest puzzle
it would indeed be like a chess puzzle a
checkmate puzzle
yup made into
[Music]
a clean win
oh wait this is actually what
was up with the king and indeed
that was wicked
really cool checkmate
indeed it was a really cool checkmate
but it started out so well for minx
unintentionally well she was gonna
castle if we just quickly replay that
moment andrea she was gonna castle the
king ended up on f8 uh but it eventually
worked out for her with this pompous to
have four box box missing that the pawn
can be taken the rook on g8 was perfect
too everything was fine for black until
the bottles gambit had to show obviously
um queen takes d8 and the queen was not
taken back unfortunately for minks
well i hope now we found our fatal
weakness so if she's just a little bit
more cautious with her pieces but you
know she's done a couple lessons we've
talked about blundering but it's just
invitable at this level um but still
like you said her opening i did not do
much opening prep and her opening was
very solid so i still think that the
next game could be a close one
i think so too this started out as a
very close one let's listen in with box
box and his preparation for this second
game starting shortly
yeah i screwed up
i didn't take this free pawn
and then i also
oh wait wait wait okay let's go back
let's go back
okay
uh i remember
looking over here
i remember saying like oh this move
feels really awkward to me i'm like why
don't i just develop for free if my
opening involves moving up one and then
frappuccinoing my bishop and then moving
up another one why don't i just skip
that step in move two i said it felt
wrong but according to the engine it
likes it
the mistake was not taking this uh pawn
immediately
oh
oh i see
i see i see i see i see
i the reason why this move was fine is
because
the engine wouldn't suggest going for
the regular strat of um pushing like
that
it makes sense though like there's no
way i can push at this point
yeah i cannot push at that point all
right
as soon as they did that was like oh i
really screwed up
oh wow
my best play was actually at this point
they just give up a night to reset the
position
that queen cycle is really funny oh wow
let's go back
oh it's because i think my queen's like
kind of trapped
wait i missed the hanging bishop
hanging knight oops
um
[Music]
i i don't i don't get it
i got the answer but i don't even know
why it was right
it doesn't even feel good
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered earn crypto by learning about
crypto with coinbase earn power up your
trading with coinbase's advanced
features get exclusive rewards when you
spend with coinbase card and much more
learn more at coinbase.com
chess
and we are back with productions for
presented by coinbase the second game
between box box and justin minx is about
to start this was in the end a win for
the favorite but minx was upper pawn
after the opening and had a really good
chance if it wasn't for the botus gambit
andrea
yeah i did i'm not gonna lie i'm a
little bit biased i sent her some
discord messages i said you got this
mink slow down no more photos gamuts i
don't know how much my advice will help
but mainly for beginners as always i say
slow down and double check your moves
because she was just she was speeding
with her king
indeed she spotted the check and
immediately she should take a bit more
time but i'm sure that she will get more
used it this is her very first pogchamps
event earlier she participated
in the bullet tournament you ladies
organized the bottas bullet championship
but we no longer have bullet format here
this is 10 minutes with a 5 second
increment so she does have time to think
her moves through it so she and once she
adapts to it i think it will go better
for her double checking her moves yeah
maybe that's where my coaching went
wrong by making her first time ever
playing chess was playing bullets um but
she did do very well for lovren in that
tournament as well um oh
gonna live like tomorrow doesn't exist
like it does no
no
no i'm not ready beautiful concert when
it's time to play things
all right the game has begun
me first amy timey time
copy me i dare you mate
i have a new voice
and indeed vlogs versus copying i don't
that's central bush
the roles have reversed
i don't know what i'm doing now okay
i'll do this
for a 200 following the opening
principles perfectly
no i think not
because my queen will eat you if you do
that
she's double checking
what the horse doing what the horse
doing my horse doing the same thing
[Music]
what's your plan here i can see your
game
i can
i can't
i can't see this game
was she keeps developing whether she
predicted bishop of these things or not
knight c3 is it good
[Music]
and back to analysis we go
all right
i mean i must say
minx is doing really good for a 200 okay
she's castled she pushed her pawn in the
centers taking out our knights and
bishops as her coach i'm very pleased it
is very difficult to place someone a
thousand rating points above you
it is indeed very difficult uh i did
briefly talk to minks about which
pompous are more important and she did
start with the central palm pushes that
open up files diagonals for one species
a4 is not one of those
highlight usually but it's not a mistake
now that she follows it up with b3 maybe
that bishop will be heading to b2 i'm
just hoping he's not a3 because both the
bishop and the queen of black is staring
at that square from the distance sorry
i'm trying to cover both squares but
yeah once again like a very comfortable
position for white where white even has
the advantage uh black has queen side
castle but since her she pushed a little
bit too early but once again it's
benefiting her later in the game because
this is actually where we want to attack
towards her king
indeed now that boxbox has castle
queenside it is a perfect setup with the
pawns and further pawn pushes could be
expected if minx realizes that she has a
chance to attack on the queen size or
put inside costly she plays rook b1
maybe in the future she will push b4
even if it's upon sacrifice it would be
a good idea to target the king
yeah i mean she's making a plan which is
once again at this level when people
don't know what to do they just start
randomly pushing pawns but she's looking
to attack towards the king she's on the
right track
i like it her intuition is the right one
placing the rook then maybe in the
future pushing the pawn i wonder if
she'll develop the c1 bishop but for now
it wasn't that simple even on b2 or d2
it wouldn't have been a very active
piece
all right maybe we could see what boxbox
is thinking we have another opportunity
for free pawn
push up
she'll take the pawn i retake
pre-moving knight takes e5
he is
looking nice
but if knight takes d5 he's got the f6
knight a guarding why did they name it
the greek guy
maybe a greek guy uh oh
minx is still playing great putting
pressure on the calculating calculating
is this checkmate
calculation time indeed what is hanging
voxbox let's see
checkmate
oh he's going for green oh wait hang on
uh i'm a little uneasy if i go here i
let her check and take this pawn
[Music]
uh i might have to play this quiet move
the question was a good idea to protect
the a7 yeah
he was calculating greek's gift doesn't
work
no if she trades for bishop
oh no i don't get to do the greek guy if
she trades
don't trade don't take
don't take billy the big ship oh okay
mix can still take it in the future but
yes
it is box box who is trying to go for
that very known sacrifice for the
checkmate attack i don't think this is
the position where it can work out oh my
god
right away
i'm gonna
i'm just gonna take this now
her intuition is great but it is very
hard to not blunder
very hard indeed after the pump pushed
to e4 the knight was attacked on f3
there weren't too many squares for the
night but she could have saved it
yeah with her intuition was great queen
d2 i'm not sure maybe she was trying to
defend this diagonal but she got into a
great position she had pressure in the
center could have traded off this dark
squared bishop now she's gonna be down a
piece but still you know still has
opportunities
especially if box boss wants to go for
the sacrifice because he kept looking at
the d6 bishop and he wants to give it up
on h2 that would equalize the material
it's not the position where the
checkmate pattern works i think he
realized that greek's gift does not work
because knight g4 is prevented from this
bishop maybe why he's trying to trade
that right now
it must be the reason but even then the
the queen is still looking at the g4
square too so he's very keen
on making it happen and yet it isn't the
right position for it he could try other
types of attack for instance by pushing
the h-bone to h5 and then knight g4 so
that the h5 could open up for the rook
yeah i mean both sides are eyeing the
kingside attack here i would that's why
i would like to see minks trade off this
bishop to try to maybe keep her h2
square a little bit safer prevent the
sack
um
let's see
never mind don't have rings all right
see what she's thinking about here
shall we tune in to our players i think
we have now mink's stream up
look at me go
i'm definitely doing something here 100
100 doing good
100 percent went in here boys absolutely
know what i'm doing
okay
he and i predicted it okay
i'm impressed that boxbox is eventually
going for that h5 push because that's
not like i don't know what the [__] to
do here
not a surprise not new half it won't
begin against the beginner bot but
i must do something here right
he wants to
i don't know i don't know why i'm trying
to calculate what he's doing
i literally don't know
what's your plan here man
what are you doing what are you doing
with greece yes ma'am
1200 iq right now he's freaking me out
he's freaking me out chad he's freaking
me out and you're all a bunch of emotes
if i see any paper that's when i get
stressed
was that stop spamming doritos i don't
know what that means
uncle owl made it
what's his plan here why is he getting
close
uh
at least she's looking for his threats
she is and i think she she was also
looking at that knight on b5 about to
take on d6 she might get rid of one of
the dangerous attacking pieces of box
box yeah i mean
she's doing good she's pushing the
b-pawns
her her random moves are still very good
i can't even think
his chest leaving regardless where do i
go from here i'm just going to move this
little lad
shouldn't
okay we could go back to the analysis
here
it wasn't a bad idea to move that little
guy oh where did that [__] come from
because she could have moved
up
but yes there was something on the
diagonal unfortunately the city pawn was
blocking by pushing the sea point the
rook is now captured
that was something that's easy to miss
especially for a beginner because the
rook in this moment is safe it only it
is only after your own move that the
diagonal has opened up and box box of
course immediately spotted and captures
the request yeah i mean though i want to
say her her before pawn was very
interesting because even if he would
have taken her to open up the file on
the king looking for some counter attack
but you know when you panic you push
pawns and then she picked a bad pawn to
push oh she finally traded off the d6
bishop she did and i was just gonna say
that before she pushed the pawn to c3
she was also hovering over the rook from
b1 to b3 she almost stepped out of the
diagonal without knowing
that there was danger so her intuition
she definitely should listen to her
intuition more often and trust herself
more
yeah and i saw some chat members saying
that it's a really difficult pairing
which it is but just to remind you guys
so the first game typically in any chess
terminal that's how it go top players
play the bottom half but as the games go
on you get paired more with people your
level and you also get put into a
bracket with people your level flash is
kind of how the tournament works
indeed we are just at the very first
matches of the group stage in this case
box box facing the lowest rated player
of his group and that's as andrea
already highlighted is how it begins but
that's not how it ends the second phase
of the tournament will feature two
brackets and in the constellation
bracket i think minx will have a good
chance against similarly beginner
opponent and by that time she will have
all the preparation and training from
these difficult match-ups because you
learn a lot when you face strong
opponents
i think foxbox is coming in with the
checkmate but like you said she's
getting the best practice
and it is indeed on the board queen
takes h2
that's what voxbox
is about
double checking it
double checking it and it's checkmate
see it gets worse when i'm thinking
she did so very well and i hope she
doesn't stress herself out too much
it's very hard because she was looking
for his plan with that h pawn and of
course a main part of chess is pattern
recognition and she wasn't very familiar
with the sack on h2 and the plan to try
to open up the king's side with the
h-pawn which is exactly what he did but
she was searching for his plan i just
unfortunately did not catch it in time
indeed she she did have the right idea
but wasn't uh exactly catching the the
way the threat was gonna take place she
constantly looked at the king's eye she
did take the the bishop on d6 which was
important for the defense of the king
but unfortunately the queen and the rook
eventually made it all the way to h2 and
this is a beautiful checkmate pattern
wasn't the greeks gift that boxbox
originally planned but still it was
about the h2 squared was this in your
opinion andrea the play of the game or
would you pick a different moment from
this match
i would say i don't want to see things
losing so not pick this one i would pick
the six move or what was it eleven move
checkmate
i vows history in terms of dispatch
between the two games which my game
between box box and just makes you find
more
memorable and which moment within that
match ah i would say both says gambit of
course no bias at all how about you anna
yeah the boat is getting certainly very
memorable and just the fact that minx
was doing amazing in that very first
game even though she mouse slipped
at the same time our opinion doesn't
matter as much as your opinion we want
you to vote for which moment of these
matches of these games you find the most
memorable and which ones should turn
into
our packages at eternal you just need to
sign up at eternal.gg connect it to your
twitch account and use the word eternal
at any point of the show where you think
that that's a highlight that's a moment
that should be remembered
forever and should be created as a
digital collectible
they will drop on september the 12th and
every single day we have three winners
per match so you can take them home for
free or if you decide to purchase the
collectibles all the proceeds from the
purchases will go to supporting grad as
our charity initiative rise above the
disorder
thank you anna um i think we're gonna
take a short break and we will be back
hopefully with an interview of our
participants
[Music]
no
do
[Music]
so
welcome back to our coverage of
functions for presented by coinbase we
are being joined by the players of this
epic battle box box and just a minx box
was congratulations but let me start
with minx
who has had her own charity initiative
for this game minx tell us about your
tweet and what how did you come up with
this set of what blunder what game loss
or checkmate is what price for charity
um well it goes cancer research and it
was because look we came in here knowing
i'd lose anyway i've told both of you my
fantastic coaches that have tried to
help me and somehow everything you said
to me has not been retained in my memory
it was
i am not one against a beginner but
still to this day i won today because
the time so in the first round that was
you know my goal
and but no so every blunder i did every
mistake i did every inaccuracy i did
every
um
piece that boxbox took i donate 10 euro
and then every
loss which was two a hundred which
wasn't surprising i calculated it
correctly
well it's going to be a lot of money to
charity but you still minx you did
exceed our expectations you followed the
principles it was a really tough match
up here i mean box box do you think
you're going to be eyeing the
championship first place prize going
head-to-head with ludwig again or any
other top players
i want to eat ludwig
that sounds like the winning
message sending it out there
i think he is watching so please tell us
about it more
yeah i recently played a different
chess.com show match against him and um
it was like a best of 15 where we played
blitz and then bullet
and he
are we left to swear
uh
we had plenty of it already with me so
i'm sure it's okay
he kicked my ass
the only reason i won is because he
completely sucks at bullet chests but
we're not gonna be playing bullet chests
in pogchamps
so i have to i have to keep training
also
he did something
unforgivable
what do you do what did he do he stole
my coach
oh no
wait who is your coach
from you
robert hess
my favorite coach
and then
yeah hes messaged me saying like i'm so
sorry i haven't been seeing your
messages recently
i'm on a vacation to the bahamas with
ludwig
oh god well box fox if you do need it
some extra coaches we would love to help
you there's plenty of them but that is
really some dirty moves
absolutely dirty
yeah i don't blame you for wanting to
eat him i think that's the only thing
that would do justice
yeah
that was really funny
but we'll say that again makes the fact
that he asked if he could curse and then
he just said ass
was incredible
we had a little preview of minx's uh
pre-game preparation which was all
family-friendly in my
i did not know you guys were going to be
watching before how i got in the room i
saw and my child was like oh i'm on
screen i'm like that's so embarrassing
not as embarrassing as the game and but
box box moving forward i hope you know
that i'm the strongest competition you
had
oh yeah i i absolutely believe it yeah i
felt the pressure with your early pawn
moves
foxbox what did you think when she chose
not to take back your queen i don't want
to talk about that
please
that was interesting
i uh
that was the most amount of shock i've
ever felt in a chess game
and like uh i've never gotten this far
so i don't know what to do here
i was just gonna add that minks just
wanted to fit in with the both the
sisters we we call it in the chess
community the boat is gambit when the
queen is blundered and that was for team
envy minks i know you did it all for
content all for the squad yeah well it
was completely planned totally not i
told i didn't even realize until after
the game you know that's the worst part
when i said blunders and i was like when
did i let him take my queen and they're
like that's when we spam the paga and
i'm like oh
wow
well for the record though minx you're
opening i don't know how you did it like
you had random mouse slips the king not
castling pushing random puns but it
would all work in your favor but of
course you know when it comes to
blunders box box has a little bit more
experience than playing uh tactically
yeah i did try to castle the first round
but it went the wrong side oh so was the
mouse slip
you
i see we were right okay
and then in game two you castles and you
were very proud of that moment so were
we that you developed your pieces went
for costly as soon as you can so you're
making progress and i think what's
important for the lower rated players in
the group stage is to see that
it's the second phase that will matter
even more the knockout stage box box
knows it well the championship wrecking
them consolation record that's where
it's going to be no path matches and
winning the matches there is what truly
will matter so until then is just to see
who goes to which bracket and you can
use these matches to improve because
playing against a stronger player always
helps you to get even better faster anna
while i'm hearing is this match there's
not much embarrassment because he's got
it but in the future massachusetts if i
lose it's just pure embarrassment and
terrible
oh no
no but in the future matches you will be
paired against players who are also
beginners like yourself so in the group
stages it can happen that you face
someone like box box who could be
playing for the trophy for winning
blockchains for you might be playing
here against the champion minx but this
match and other matches in the group
stage can help you get better before
they make it to the knockout stage so
it's important to play as best as you
can even if the result often times feels
very one-sided and these are difficult
games but it will help you get better
for the later stage of the tournament so
you guys are so sweet to me
that was true
yeah like poor box box he had it in the
game but they're like room for me the
whole time it's like well it's only
because they knew how bad i was box box
oh no i think it's really cool when
people learn i i'm all for them
supporting you did you see uh the chat
vote
it was 99
one point something million for box box
and there was like 10 000 for me
the votes
yeah it was 99 to 1 and i was like well
you know what boys
they're not wrong
i mean with 1 000 rating difference you
know but i do have one last question for
box box because he was trading so
intensely we couldn't even get his
attention from his puzzles and then even
after he won those both games he was
analyzing both of them so what is your
preparation plan for your next pogchamps
game now that robert hess has deserted
you on his vacation with ludwig yeah all
right now that i don't have my main
coach
i um
i had to walk over
to my front door
open it
to the line of grand masters asking to
coach me
oh must be hard yeah i'll have to pick
from one of them
all right no actually though i uh i got
offers from
mr daniel naradicki
uh and uh a nice gm that i played with
in their hand and brain uh mr krikor i'm
excited to work with them
yeah i'm really excited
you did great as a team with cricor i
felt it very closely i don't know if you
realize but i was the brain for for i'm
peter and we got crushed by your team so
that was definitely good teamwork and
that dania is known as a very good coach
preparing charlie morris critical for
that sixth move win against sqc so i
think you'll be happy with both coaches
okay thank you guys both of you
congratulations boxbox and minx i am
still a proud coach even though you both
has gambited and good luck it was after
you box box i'm rooting for you against
ludwig i'll be cheering you on thanks
thanks
yeah and thanks so much for having us
here oh they left
there was a very wholesome moment there
between the players rooting for each
other i think we could still hear pogba
so don't worry that was still part of
the show part of the plan we just went
to a different slide but on that note i
think we will soon be getting ready for
the next match up in the meantime you
shout out to our sponsor coinbase
obviously this event wouldn't be
possible without their help and and this
time also just a call to action because
we always do obviously um if you want to
get five dollars in bitcoin
do go to coinbase.com slash chess and
with your sign up you will receive for
free
the five dollars in bitcoin listening to
andra's financial advice this is a good
future investment and it cost you
nothing
yeah look i have lost based on this
advice of my sister thousands and
thousands of dollar in crypto but you
guys have nothing to lose because you
get money for free so unlike me you know
your your chances are much better but um
otherwise than crypto i'm really excited
for this matchup we have mr beast and
ludwig where do you have the prediction
going almost three million points on
ludwig and a hundred thousand on mr
beast kind of similar to our last game
but you know maybe mr bc could perform
some under the table bribes you know
something for the charity you never know
what might happen
let's listen to him with nothing and his
preparation this is a rematch from the
previous park champs not week one at
function three but maybe mr beast has
come with a stronger preparation this
time
when do you get rid of the s in stakes
now we're not betting like wag you
here is the thread
ladies and
gentlemen
mr beast
i dm'd him good luck today or tweeted at
him all right
he replied you're done for i said loser
has to post a picture on their instagram
and a cat made outfit
he said unlike you i don't own a cat
made outfit to which i replied oh ho i'm
mr beast i can't afford a cabinet it's a
cat made outfit bro
you literally walk around going
and i quote
this is a lamborghini
okay so he's got a lambo but he can't
afford a cat made outfit
and then he said if he can go white
pieces first then it's it's a deal so
chess.com make sure he gets white pieces
first if it's black pieces first i abort
okay
does it i i don't care what i'm aborting
if it's uh if i get the white pieces
he's gotta start with the white pieces
also he well
you guys want some secret secret inside
information
jimmy i can call him jimmy because we
text each other am i allowed to swear on
this
jimmy's being a bit of ass in the
messages
and uh
he says
i don't know what i'm doing today
and i
being a an avid fan of mr beast but also
of poker know that this man has not been
putting his free time into chess anymore
all right queen's gambit era is over for
this guy he's been playing poker with
the most crazy poker players of all time
phil hellmuth and tom dwan i've seen it
on instagram which is crazy
that's crazy
and then i'm like i know i've been
seeing that you've been playing poker
we talked for a bit
and i say all right well if this chess
match goes awry for you let's do heads
of poker
you know what his next message was
deal 100k
does he think the subathon is still
happening
does he think i'm sleeping on stream a
hundred [__] rex
no shot
i can't pull out a hundred racks for a
heads-up poker match
what does he think's happening
i got i got people to pay i got bills to
pay
i still got a 30-year mortgage
i can't do that
i gotta pay shake drizzle to edit my
youtube videos slime to fart in front of
me in the office and do my taxes and
aiden to run the merch site
see
if i win the game maybe we'll set up a
heads up match all right
but i have to win first
actual [__] stop calling me poor stop
calling me poor because i can't do a 100
000 heads-up match
that is actually bullying it's poor
shaming
it is not it's not like obs that's me
most people can't
okay i'm not this is not weird if i'm
not the weird one here you guys this
story was supposed to be me relating to
you guys and then you guys ended up just
bullying me for not having 100k to drop
a bugger
i am not
so poor
okay all right this was i don't know why
i brought up this story anyway we'll see
what happens i think i know exactly what
mr beast is gonna do because
my coach
robert hess
my one and only coach
who likes me way more than box boxes
stupid idiot ass
has told me a brilliant game plan for
the first six moves
and so if you see me with the lead in
the first six understand that was a
lesson from hess
[Music]
i learned a thing from hess
i will have taken that
and
implemented it into my game
[Music]
how much do i pay hess
dude hess is the most annoying guy ever
and by annoying i mean he's like so
sweet and i'm such a [__] [__] and
so it's so hard because i just want to
keep being a dick but anytime i am he
just responds with niceness
and it's like ugh
and so when he was coaching me all
throughout the the last pog champs he
was like he was like super sweet he's
like no dude honestly man i don't want
any payment like
i always say if my students do well
that's all them and if they do bad
that's on me like i don't want any
payment man
and so i had to like secretly wire money
into his account
and it wasn't like a small i think i
gave him like all the winnings i had
gotten from pogchamps plus a little bit
right
in the last pog champs
and he never ever ever said anything
about it for like weeks and then finally
i was like
did you like get the money
he's like oh yeah but it's like that's
not what it's about and i'm like yeah i
know but like i just want to make sure
that you got
he's so anti getting paid he didn't even
like care he didn't mean like
and it's not like he didn't care like mr
beast doesn't care because mr beast has
lost all idea of what money is
he is a real one
although can we can we stop being nice
to hess can we flame hess in chat
hess literally left on vacation today
this is the
this is it everybody the big matchup of
today a rematch perhaps
box change 3 featured ludwig beating mr
beast in the group stage and now the two
are back and there's a lot on the line
last time they played for 10k for
charity this time it's a cat made outfit
andrea what do you think about that
tweet that we have been reading earlier
ludwig wishing good luck and that all
the way ended up all the way going to
a basically a deal about a potential cat
made outfit for the loser yeah i mean
ludwig like willingly wears those so i
don't really know if this is a deal or
just ludwig trying to justify his next
um outfit appearance but there was a lot
of heated pregame trash talk ludwig's
saying mr beast has been spending his
time playing poker saying he has no
concept of money i love mr beast i don't
know maybe he's gonna trash talk him
maybe he's gonna be nice but ludwig's
always you can rely on him to bring on
the heat and the cat suits
the heat and the cat suit is on and lot
of week requested to start the first
game with the black pieces that was mr
beast's condition for accepting the cat
with outfit deal so if mr beast has the
white pieces in the first game then the
deal is on indeed
yeah i was not expecting that i don't
know how much of an advantage you'll
give mr beast
however i'm very excited to see this
next friend of cat suits and i haven't
yet to see mr beast in the cat suit
himself
he didn't did say the love that he
doesn't own one and then nothing was
like oh yeah oh mr beast i can't afford
the cat little outfit i love the trash
talking friendly trash talking with with
the two on twitter it's obviously just
cool banter and the game is about to
start ludwig is streaming on his channel
and we can see that mr beast with the
big smile and the beast t-shirt
yep just waiting i'm following him right
now as we speak oh okay it started i'm
going to try it and then one more time i
think
we've got ludwig's perspective of his
playing the scandinavian defense as he
did in their game at pogchamps 3. i
think he was supposed to go
something else
all right we're just gonna do a regular
scandy
maybe it's with the white pieces
i'm forgetting
okay he's double fan cuddling i have no
idea how to deal with this
okay normally you're supposed to make
this move to block the bishop but if the
bishop fianchettos is that movie even
necessary
i imagine not so i'll just fish her bish
i'll just fish your bish night castle
pawn bishop
or no maybe pawn
yeah yeah
night
castle
move the king over one
pawn up
probably queen back because he's
probably gonna put some pressure by
moving this up
song's fire dude
oh is he pawn rushing me
awesome
all right well i'm still going for it
because our analysis board because that
was a big missed opportunity by mr beast
after ludwig developed the bishop to f5
the pawn on b7 was hanging and it's not
only about the pawn but the rook that
was trapped in the corner mr beast would
have been up a lot of material nothing
was looking at that part of the board
but was too focused on his own
development getting the knight out
pushing the pawn castle and it was
missed by both players that bishop b7
would have been an extremely strong move
for white yeah both opponents are tunnel
visioning but i must say compared to mr
beast's last performance i think that
ludwig is underestimating how much
preparation he did like he actually has
a very comfortable position i like this
he's gaining the space kicking out this
bishop
beautiful development with the bishops i
think uh ludwig was underestimating him
a bit
and here there would be a beautiful
tactical pattern to mysteries continues
with quick developing moves but he also
could have captured the pawn on a7 with
the check bishop takes a7 and if the
king takes back knight b5 wins the queen
that would have been another boat says
gambit i don't think ludwig would have
taken
he would have not had taken for sure but
it was then gonna be opponent for mr
beast and attack against the king it was
again a missed opportunity it seems like
mr beast does have a good development
great position but it would have been
even better if he spent a little bit
more time on those decisions
but ludwig saw it
he spotted it now pushes the pawn so
that knight b5 or bishop a7 is no longer
an issue
very nice
mr beast is thinking
will he cause a king side or queen side
i wonder
he just says like okay and then shakes
his head a little bit and then silence
and then one word it's a little bit hard
to follow his thought process
he
all right sticking with the plan
sticking with the plan so he wanted to
contest
he seems very happy with this play it is
a little risky castling towards the rook
and the queen we might have another box
box mate i would have liked a queen side
castle uh let's listen to ludwig as well
let's do so
[Music]
he could go forward one actually
yeah i guess i didn't think about that
at the [__] all
and that's a great decision by mr beast
to keep the question position close
defended once attacked twice
[Music]
i can go back here i could also go back
here
what was his pawn doing
oh wait
no
i thought i could go here for a moment
and then if um takes takes takes queen
takes it's undefended but it's also not
undefended that was just wrong
all right let's just
here here here right
now it's defended twice
doesn't have too many good squares
yeah let's go back to the board
97 was the choice of ludwig there
weren't too many good moves but that
night he was trying to calculate whether
there were any tactics with the pin on
the d5 but indeed he had to retreat
either to h7 or to the a string and it's
not a very cool
future perspective for that knight on
the edge of the board the idea of
opening up the position with h5 was the
right one but i think ludwig fully
missed that mr beast can push g5 that
was a really good response because if he
had not pushed it after opening up the
h5 even h6 g4 it would have been a
really strong attack for ludwig
yeah no i mean mr b's display has really
impressed me here i would like to see
him maybe actually i don't even know
face fro would be the correct idea um he
didn't just blunder upon but once again
opening up the file could benefit him
he's attacking towards his opponent's
king just like what ludwig was doing but
he's playing it seems like a much closer
matchup than i expected it looks like a
very close matchup and i love his pawn
blunder i think he's doing it on purpose
because if the queen takes the pawn then
you have rook b1 and the b7 pawn is in
trouble as well as the king he's happy
about it
yeah
it's happening rugby one now with
whichever rook and then the queen has to
go rook takes b7 it's almost a checkmate
attack then the king will be in trouble
oh my god
it's happening he sees it did he
calculate this all we got was those
little happy groans but i think that
means yes i see the mates
before things are going good
so many things that you're being very
good
indeed let's listen
i just gotta i just gotta keep firing
things at them keep firing things is he
gonna no he didn't see it
he's still attacking but now ludwig will
have a chance to defend
we are going full force
on
his
king
i don't know
c6 blocks the diagonal that's a good
decision dude he's crushing it still it
is so difficult to defend if the rook
comes to b1 then b7 eventually
will have to fall and this this is such
a difficult position for ludwig even if
b7 wasn't taken immediately
[Music]
he is no longer smiling
very focused trying to save that king
he's imagining the cat suit already
being fight would be a good attempt at
least it prevents the media disaster
nice
i think he will go for it he is really
considering b5 and then what happens
after the capture i'm in trouble smiley
face
ludwig knows it nothing knows that mr
beast can put even more wood on that
fire he is building if he pushes the a
pawn to yeah let's go back to the game
let's let's show it anna's talking about
nice so in this moment ludwig is so far
holding that attack that the two rooks
were building up against the black king
but if mr beast pushes a4 that will help
the attack of white by trading the a
pawn on b5 and then a potential
sacrifice perhaps with knight takes b5
and then the rooks will be attacking
with full force that's the full force
mysteries was talking about he just
should not
okay i was told that this man did like
one joke
don't stop
attacking
he has been grinding
if you're not on the left side of the
board hidden as king i don't want
he can have
my king i don't know that's the spirit
he's killing it oh my goodness
loving he's trying to escape he's
running to c7 with his king at least
stepping out of the b fight again good
instinct to try to defend by fleeing
but now can he
even sacrifice yeah there's so much play
the queen coming in the rook taking the
bishops are just perfectly placed
controlling all these squares of the
king
this exact would be just fantastic
killer position from mr beast is already
showing mate in a few months but a few
10 11 12 moves
he doesn't have to calculate all the way
till mid but will he sacrifice either
with the knight capturing on b5 or the
rope because both are possible
loving is so focused he knows that this
is a very troublesome situation i got
rook here and then move my pawn up i
have three defenders
thoughts
[Music]
oh
he was already calculating it earlier i
showed it earlier because mr peace was
ready to
sacrifice his rook
[__] it
i'm not gonna think about it okay let's
go back to mr beast cam he's talking
he's smiling
he's looking very pleased
wait this isn't supposed to happen i
didn't actually think i had a chance
yo you got to be kidding me
okay
hold on
oh i was i don't believe it
now he just needs to figure out how to
get the rest of the pieces through the
king
keeps attack going
see what he's thinking about many
options you could maybe bring the queen
queen to a5 or queen to c3 check uh the
bishop can still make it to b72 but i
think he kind of forgot about it
look at that bringing this queen even
this poker play has been somehow
benefiting his chess player he just been
grinding away he's playing so good
i think he was riding a lot of chess
games too
back
backstage because this is a great game
by mr beast
he just doesn't believe it's real
oh yeah his move was even better than
mine
literally winning
there is no move only bishop c7 but that
would have led to a disastrous attack to
ludwig is giving up the knight on c5
mrvis is calculating the capture
i mean he's just winning up so much
material now
i think uh mr beast is gonna secure the
win
and he's gonna be checkmate soon with
the queen and rook also the bishop if he
brings it in
i'd love to go watch ludwig's misery now
to see the sad
work on his face
poor ludwig he's one of the favorites
but suffering now
i think right here check
and then i go here and then bishop check
this is about mate
he's right
it's very close to mate in a few moves
[Music]
oh
maybe if mr beast
he could have given a few checks okay
i don't think he's the best move but
it's not the worst move either wait wait
let's look at the board i think he's
planning a trick made in two here with a
rook threat and he's celebrating he was
clapping a little bit
things are going good
he's cutting the king he took the pawn i
believe not just for the pawn but to cut
the king on the e5 and not let it flee
yo is anyone else watching this what
nobody
b we have a whole produced show
he's like sitting not streaming like
in his house in his room
it's just a chill chess game nobody's
watching i think it's still comedy that
it's actually happening that he's a few
moves away from checkmating one of the
favorites [__] what's gonna happen
it's checkmate in two now will he play
it
stay big brain
yeah four minutes left
i don't want to say anything i want to
hear everything he says so he finds me
the tension in the air
so focused he goes back to b5 with the
queen which wasn't his initial idea
rook jack would have left to check
meeting too but this is of course still
completely winning it just made the king
have somewhere to run to
he needs to try to prevent the king from
running to f8
okay he'll get back there there you go
he's doing we'll try again
he's not letting ludwig skin king run
away loving was so close that was making
it back to f8 and g8 hiding there but mr
beast
uh it's just on his a game in this very
first game of the match yeah chad is
saying a throw in coming i don't believe
it i think mr beast is on his a game you
know he missed the maiden two but he's
still killing it here no protest gambit
incoming
no way
let's see if ludwig will go back to d7
with the king or try to cover block with
the rook on d6 that's what he chooses
that gives some hope for black for
survival because at least it's not that
obvious which one is the next right
check which one is the next right move
so let's see if we'll if we're gonna
have the rook joining the attack with
rook b7 check or will it be another
queen check that mr beast chooses to try
to hunt down the king
i'm not drinking it don't say that
see
so focused three minutes left
i do like that he he takes his
calculations very seriously seriously
knight to f4 bringing closer yet another
piece toward the black king to help the
attack i like that idea now the knight
could give a check on d5 as well so he
had a few chances to bring the rook to
b7 or to e1 but he chooses to bring
another piece which is also good of
course now the knight is part of the
attack
ludwig is being very sneaky defending
his rook so his king can escape and
maybe gonna try to play the clock
let's listen in with his thoughts in
this difficult situation
it's like he forgot about this rook
[Music]
sing it
check
he's right that it feels like mr [__]
forgot about the rook for these last few
moves
but h4 makes sense too it makes this h7
knight very sad a very set piece
[Music]
getting into time scrambles here and the
great choice by ludwig to try to bring
that knight back into the game and help
the defense of the king so better
practical chances for survival for sure
i mean he can't get a checkmate with
just this queen and he's not bringing
the rook in and i'm on dark squares only
with the light squared bishop
so i assume if he's if he hasn't
recognized that he has a rook yet and he
hasn't brought this guy in for a check
then he's probably gonna just move pawns
oh and there we go
he's mowing the rook interesting that he
didn't move it all the way down
he's moving into the a5
no what is gambit's right andrea
all right i mean mr beast is used to
performing under high pressure he's been
what like chased by a hitman before he
can win a chess game with two minutes
left okay he's gonna see this
oh this works too not winning the rook
but he's coming towards the king
coming towards the the king and not
leaving the queen hanging that's
important too and park champs do not
play the both this gambit too often rook
e6 now the queen has to move again
could this be another scripted chase
where ludwig pretends his king is about
to be sniped and then we get an upset
let's see
hopefully don't worry about this game it
says you were showing with the arrow
andrea they were put there was a
potential queen check that would have
been about this game with queen d4 is a
much better move targeting the g7 pawn
so focus both players are barely talking
in this moment
ludwig i mean even against me with time
odds games he knows how to flag someone
that's exactly he's trying to think of
his trickiest defense he can maybe block
with the knights
pack
and that there's counter play
i was i was just gonna add that at the
same time mr beast loves bullet chess he
loves the adrenaline rush i think he
doesn't mind that much that he's going
low on time yeah he i have heard he does
play a lot of blitz
f8 guards the pawn and make sure that
there's no immediate attack this is
interesting a rook tray so maybe that's
why he moved the rook to a1 to end up
trading and that's also a very pragmatic
decision he's up material he's trying to
simplify the position by trading one of
the rooks of ludwig
i mean i like this he's trying to attack
the defender of the knights and he is
performing well under time pressure
he is and maybe instead of the checkmate
attack that he was already going for
we're just gonna see his c and d pawns
becoming a protagonist too if he starts
pushing the past bones and promote it to
a queen
no more joyful jolly beasts
he's becomes
yeah
he knows it's very serious now and time
pressure is approaching i've never seen
this man hold a straight face for so
long never mind he just broke it
that queen check again tickling the king
he's really liking it
that was a great great move android we
just show it for him oh
[Music]
will mr bc that this is actually oh
not winning the queen of bishop could
have taken the night
it's oh my god it's happening so quickly
everything's fine everything's fine he
could have put the sleepon though to not
give it to ludwig
he celebrated just a little bit too
early and i don't want this together for
the millionth time today
that was ludwig's last chance that night
check the leadership could have captured
it
yep just to show one more time mr beast
could have taken with this bishop all
right back to the game
still winning for white but it is a
critical end game
it's no longer as simple as a queen of
he now needs to be very technical about
this end game and know how to promote
the pawn
so how would i win this anna
i think for now the white king could
make it to the king side but perhaps a
bishop c6 move to start with so that you
prevent the black king from approaching
your past pawn but this isn't simple at
all
yes some ideas to come chase the pawns
if he's really thinking ahead but he
only has 1 minute 30 he could prevent
the king
very tough situation to be in
really tough but i can't believe we are
here when mr beast was up a queen and he
even found the tactics to win the rook
of ludwig he only just needed to spot
that the bishop was controlling the
square where ludwig went for a night
fork it was a check the queen was
hanging but the bishop of mr beast could
have captured it if he had realized from
the distance the bishop
oh my gosh he found it i was going to
say let's look into ludwig because
ludwig was also predicting great endgame
moves here
okay wait if i check here
[Music]
i'm feeling just us
music
it is a very difficult end game for
rodrik still but considering he was down
on the queen and could have gotten
checkmate couple of times this is
[Music]
oh i think going for this ponzi mistake
because if i get this pawn then he goes
here then he takes this
and then i can't go back i'd have to go
here
and i can't move my king
and mr beast moves the bishop away
holding that diagonal that keeps the
blacking away from the passport nicely
done knight a6 setting up a potential
knight fork now mr beast needs to move
out of it and he does play kingdom
seventy girls
play
i mean playing it perfectly yeah the
fact that he found this bishop concept
cutting off the king with the plan of
using his king to chase these pawns i
mean there's no way like these end game
plans are very impressive to find at
this level you sing every attack
every single attack indeed i think lavi
will now try to attack the white pawns
with knight e4 that will attack both the
d6 phone and the f2 pawn but
it isn't that problematic if mr beast
doesn't hang the bishop too because
apart from the vicious knight d6 will
also pick up the bishop so he oh he's
pushing the pawn which seemed like the
best move maybe it actually is still all
right but he's it is i mean id6 the evil
bar took a big jump i was even i mean
he's seeing better chest than me i was
worried to push it so early thinking the
knight might catch it but after 96 king
e6
no way
after 96 i think white will have to
start taking the king side pawns because
the bishop is gone
he takes on g5 but that is protected
let's go to ludwig's stream and see what
he's saying
mr beast is not taking it
wow he just ignored it
okay
all right now my new plan is to uh draw
if i kill this pawn
then there's nothing he can do i'm still
mated
i don't know i can move here
no [__] i'm not still made it at all
true but he does have better chances the
less pawns the better of course for
black
i don't think
here buddy
this is not a draw
where will mr beast move his king
he's going to find the right
and he does that move is great prevents
the knight from jumping to f6 and now
he's ready to push the h pawn
i still can't believe what happened
earlier the hanging pieces but
yeah i don't know what happened with
knight g5 but
that was
no i can't i'm so in the heat of time
for sure
he doesn't want to talk because he's low
on time
love he gives up the night for that
point that was his plan but he cannot
hold the deep one with just the king
because there will be a moment that we
call
when he has to get out of the blockade
now he just has to figure out to get his
king to see c7 and he's winning or e7
he's doing it oh my goodness
wow he's doing it king e7 and the pawn
promotes next move texas i'm so happy
i really thought i jinxed him i really
thought i did
i guess we can style
the game if it's gonna be still made but
mr beast is back on his a-game he did
miss
a winning opportunity a couple of times
earlier but now let's see that technique
and if he can checkmate and not still
meet
got plenty of time
the king coming closer and he knows it
oh he knows he's happy
[Laughter]
i can't believe i just beat him oh my
gosh
yes
oh my gosh none of you none of you
thought i was gonna beat this man none
of you look at that that is right oh my
gosh
oh my god did anyone just see what i
just did
holy crap
oh my gosh
i mean remember the prediction what was
it like freaking seven million to a
hundred thousand he has a point none of
you believed in him he came out of here
literally
insane tactics what a great game for mr
beast
it has been an amazing game he had the
upper hand for most of the game it was
only that knight f3 check moment where
where if he had noticed the bishop he
would have won the game much earlier but
still even in an end game where it was
just the extra pawns he managed to
convert it with really good technique i
am impressed and now it is ludwig who
has to
make a comeback there will be a second
game ludwig with the white pieces and if
he wins we will see a tiebreaker but
will he win mr beast is on his a game
let's listen in with ludwig and see his
thoughts right before the second game
begins
i don't know i don't think i can do this
much better
yeah i don't think i would have done
this much better
uh
dude he was [__] cracked as [__]
his opening was nuts
that's a blunder
oh wow it is a huge blunder i don't even
[__] notice
my god
i told you guys miss you guys had 90 10
odds i was like no shot it's 90 10. mr
beast is [__] good he made me sweat
last time he's making me sweat this time
too
he's [__] goated dude
he prepares specific lines against me
and i'm a [__] one trick i do the
same exact opening line
although i think i could have played
that game better i don't think he would
have played it as well but i was also i
was low on time
i guess i had a minute
but he's definitely
although i lost then i have no room to
trash shock which i'm not trying to do i
i don't feel too bad because i i think
the fact that he missed like
like how many mates did he have chat
like how many [__] mates
he had may in eleven made in five eight
and four main two main ten made nine
made in three main two main
one no maiden 11.
he had like a hundred made opportunities
from the uh
like the dead ass 20th turn and it went
which means that i am not dealing with a
pro so i am allowed to make mistakes
just not as many as i currently made
uh this time my battle plan with hess
lost
i had to donate you and tell you that
you missed a night fork at the end game
you could have taken his bishop um
i mean the only place where i see any
sort of
uh ability to win was right here
and had nothing to do with the knife
work this was my losing move
was not doing this
i don't know why
check out learn chess with dr wolf the
virtual chess coach available now with a
one week free trial on both ios and
android if you are new to jazz or just
need a refresher this is the virtual
chess coach that will show you
everything you need to know is the next
best thing to learning from a real
person you can download it now as i said
both on ios and android andrea i think
we need to be just as good as dr wolf as
coaches because ludwig has robert has mr
beast possibly has a coach too it feels
like he has been actually training
practicing for the tournament ludwig
didn't expect it he thought that he was
busy obviously with his many youtube
channels and his poker none of you look
at that
okay to be fair i thought you might
it's not too much it's true a lot of it
gave much better odds to mr beast so
we're gonna be starting the next game
here
so just ready
this is
so unbelievable in a sense that mr beast
is clearly the underdog
he himself didn't believe that he was
gonna have a chance
and he
basically
went for the attack full force as he
said and he had a checkmate attack that
ended up giving him a clean up
couple of missed opportunities but
overall
he had the upper hand for
the majority of the game if not the
entirety and now with the black pieces
can he hold it he just needs a draw all
right i'm i mean there was so many pure
moments you could see his pure joy i'm
very curious if he's been doing
undercover training we're going to find
out right now see if his opening as
black is going to be solid and as white
as the last game
um
yeah it's probably
not gonna end well
playing the petrol of offering the e5
pawn this is the russian defense
taking on e4 is not the best because now
if the knight moves away there's a very
nasty discovery check
i think he might have confused his
opening preparation
well or maybe there wasn't preparation
who knows
good point mr beast thank you
he
defends well based on those calculations
i think he knows he's in trouble i'm
very curious if robert hess even though
he's currently taking a vacation if he
had time to prepare ludwig for this and
ludwig knows this trap here
i think he does based on his last move
d3 that is the right move if the knight
moves away
then there would have been big trouble
with knight c6 discover check winning
the queen f6 mr beast is trying to get
the white knight
um as in uh exchange for his hanging
knight but usually the f pawn push is
punished by a queen check on h5 will
ludwig see it will ludwig see that he
could give that check c has this is what
happens when you take a vacation
this could still be good if he sees the
check now because queen h5 check will
lead to
the e5 pawn being taken
he's not looking at it as of now
all right let's do this and develop with
tempo
he takes on d5 but that will have mr
beast the guarded e5 pawn queen h5 check
was a missed opportunity the previous
move and earlier too
is this a death note track
very fitting for uh
ludwig's last game
very fitting indeed mr beast might get
away with this dubious opening where he
he could have been punished if we just
quickly show it andra that that queen h5
check was a very strong move whether
here instead of taking and after g6
queen takes e5 would give a check and
pick up the rook in the corner so that
would help oh my goodness not a very
good move for black pawn to g6 and even
earlier without taking the 90 screen h5
check was a very strong move none of
this happened so the current situation
is that the check is no longer that big
of a deal
vladimir's last game what are you trying
to tell us yeah guys i mean the death
note music queueing this is like the
biggest upset of the century something
isn't right i don't know
we have both players extremely focused
let's tune in with ludwig again if we
can listen to the music or his thoughts
[Music]
he's seeing it but it's too late
too late
too late for ludwig
your fate has come sir
he still has the upper hand and he could
go for ideas with move like knight to b5
um but let's just do this i think i beat
him in a regular game of chess so let's
try to trade the queens to get my bishop
in my night out early
[Music]
and then castle fast
it makes sense for the development of
the bishop but mr business out of danger
now we are heading toward an endgame
where the e5 pawn could be a weakness
but so let me make this holding on to it
i'm worried that if i do this actually
no this is fine if i do this first
i'm hoping he goes here so i can trade
so then i can play this move
[Music]
that is smart to try to trade the bishop
because he noticed that after knight d5
or knight b56
holy [__]
i have to say the soundtrack is
perfectly fitted for the tournament
very dramatic moment mr beast now
chasing the bishop of ludwig the e5 pawn
is becoming a target again
as it has been for the majority of this
game but no peace down no major loss has
happened so far it's equal material and
even if that pawn will drop i think
that's the least after this troublesome
opening where mr beast could have been
down
perhaps the rook or the king would have
suffered a very big attack knight to d4
trying to attack but that leaves the e5
pawn hanging and both the knight and the
rook will be in the air it's not just
about the pawn anymore
oh every he he got out of that opening
let's see if ludwig is gonna see this
let's listen in
he's not looking at it
where is the death note music what is
the silence
let me just castle
he didn't see it he did not capture the
pawn on e5 he's probably gonna move this
bishop or this bishop soon i think he's
too much in his head but this is also an
unprotected piece so he might go right
here
mr beast would be ludwig's biggest
weakness
who would have thought it's all about
the cat made out fizz
okay
vulnerabilities check him
bishop g7 guarded the pawns of bishop e5
no longer an issue bishop g6 is a good
move of course but bishop takes e5 would
have been a lot bigger trouble for black
oh
okay
let's go back to the game let's let's go
back the other ones are good and this
one not so much all right so i mean the
email bar
sorry chad maybe you liked it maya just
a little bit too aggressive for me um
the email bar has jumped drastically
anna i honestly don't know why do you
that king on d7 unfortunately there's no
very well placed it's on the same fight
where ludwig's rook is i wonder if
ludwig would try to exploit it uh with a
move like knight to b5 or knight e2 he's
also threatening c3 which would win a
piece and the king is blocking the
development of the c8 bishop so multiple
issues with that choice i think it was a
difficult one the king didn't have many
good squares to go to but certainly d7
wasn't the right one
yeah i assumed there was like a winning
tactic but yes it's very tricky for mr
beast i mean he's putting his king on
this diagonal he's blocking his own
pieces he's not doing as well as this
first game but i mean we have found
ludwig's biggest weakness anything can
happen
they want a musician
let's go back to ludwig i was going to
steal the music you hear what he thinks
about c3 he already did it he already
spotted it
[Music]
he's winning the piece indeed the knight
couldn't move away because of the pin on
the d file
he has to take with this one
which is even worse for him
and even that pawn can be taken if not
to expose the other pin the g3 bishop
pinning the e5 pawn he's back i want to
bring my king in but i'm
[Music]
so he saw that the iphone couldn't take
because of the pin but will he see that
he can capture the pawn on d4
[Music]
if i could trap the king here that seems
good for me
he did move the king to beaver media
therefore that makes perfect sense too
all right yeah so ludwig did not take
this pin pawn let's see
i mean there's not many squares that
black can really run out of the pin here
he walks into another one still pinned
you have to maybe go to like b6 which
isn't very pleasant
i wonder if mr beast will move the king
again or will he now take this
opportunity to develop the c8 bishop it
would be great to get that bishop into
the game and also connect the rooks
yup developing move would be very nice
it's just hard because he's already down
material so even after that
i think they take here his position
might start to crumble but it might be
the first tie break so far in pogchamps
which would be very entertaining knowing
both players have practiced their
bullets so they're good under time
pressure
yeah it would be a blitz tiebreaker if
logic manages to win this game we will
need to decide with the blitz tiebreaker
who will be the overall winner of the
match but mr beast is guaranteed at
least one point because winning after a
tiebreaker is not the same for the score
as if you win 2-0 or one and a half half
in the rapid portion so doing extremely
well ex his own expectations i think he
already surpassed his own expectations
in the first game and he still has
chances to hang in here if ludwig
doesn't see that that pawn on d4 can be
taken in the future that pawn is a past
bone it could cause some trouble even if
objectively the position for black is
obviously lost
you could try some tricky moves like
this
i mean he'd probably be pushed right
away by the f3 pawn but maybe he's
looking for uh some tactics as we speak
he hasn't said a word so far not a smile
across his face he's completely zoned in
it's a very different mr beast uh in
comparison to the one that played the
first game with the all-in attack he did
so well in that game and and maybe some
of his his energy uh
is being drained by that first game it
was a long game in the end it was a
minor piece and game that he had to win
but what a game it was for mr beast and
i i believe that even though lavig
obviously is upper piece he's the higher
rated player but everyone makes mistakes
and nothing can still go wrong too so
i'm expecting that the evaluation bar
will still have a few swings here and
there maybe not fully depends on how
ludwig will continue let's see if bishop
g4 or any other move that mr beast is
considering he's taking very seriously
this decision
yeah who knows he's been he's been
letting his clock run for a while maybe
he's thinking of his next thumbnail
maybe he's trying to write down ludwig
in his notebook we don't know what he's
thinking about but we're hoping he's
calculating but he's almost he's lower
than
half the time here it's getting tricky
he has never spent this much time in the
mesh not even when he was close to
checkmate and could have calculated
checkmates i'm really
wondering if he didn't see that
assistant okay we've got to move we
gotta move um he did see it he was just
very focused on whether to move the king
the bishop or the rook rook the eighth
he's guarding that pawn that is oh my
god
he doesn't take it
yeah it could have still been taken
because both the white rick and the
knights were attacking it but it gives
the check that he wanted he wanted to
get the rook to the c5
and yes i did steal that chat that joke
from chat i have no problem admitting to
it
i always fall for all the jokes the
memes the pranks well is ludwig falling
for any of that let's listen in with him
and what does he think of the current
situation
extremely focused and rook c5 is a great
move putting pressure on the central
pawn of mr beast that's a pawn that was
in trouble from the beginning and now
it's being taken
otherwise getting more comfortable
and the music is getting more cheerful
too
check
take
[Music]
if he moves forward he might not see the
backwards bishop
although that will pin myself actually
[Music]
so i actually have to take with my rook
interestingly rent
oh
okay that was missed
that was a mistake is a good move i
could just [__] blunder smiley face
oh no the tilt is coming
the sneaky rook of mr beast coming in
from the left to swing over to the right
and capture that hanging bishop
still though he can't press the time
here
so let's just quickly show andrea what
happened every day a6 move and what was
the choice of ludwig later so rook takes
e5 rook a6 and ludwig didn't see the
threat on
bishop it was very sneaky it's been
tunnel visually vision whatever that
word is all day so you know sometimes
happens to me in real life chess when
they move so small in the corners don't
see it we're getting old you know our
eyes aren't good exactly we are all
getting old here
um young lady i'm like twice as old as
you but we're certainly getting very old
and that was
meaning that now the evaluation bar is
back to practically equality mr beast
with the chances here to save the game
and if he holds it he will be winning
the match of today
all right i mean mr beast pushing with
the passpond he has the battery here
everything is perfectly aligned but he's
not gonna be able to get that pawn
further much more it's not an easy plan
maybe he could finally activate his
bishop um ludwig can still block there's
a lot of ideas here for black
i can't believe that from a piece of it
ended up being equal material equal
number of pawns uh no i'm very bad at
counting it's not exactly
i'm not equal number of pieces if the
picture is taken he didn't see it last
time my never mind never mind my
prediction is wrong
all right and start seeing it and
capturing it let's listen in with ludwig
now what a relief for him
that we're 1200 rated at best
all right
mr b is just very generous and he always
likes to return the favor ludwig gives
him a bishop he gives a bishop i mean
he's known for giving things away come
on indeed he's always very generous but
this one was a bit painful to him
because he just made it back into the
game with chances to hold
and then he blundered his bishop back
however he did squeeze oh
i guess last time gave me he was winning
um but his end game play matches
ludwig's pretty close
however ludwig has so many extra pawns
along with this knight and yup just
simplify okay i think this is gigi
takes with the rook indeed now it's up a
night and two pawns as well lulu just
needs to
create a passport he can try to either
take another pawn on the queen's side or
the king's side and then create a
passport slowly but surely this i think
he will convert with great technique now
the knight is heading over to the king
side
yup ludwig is coming with the knight
hoping to chase this pawn
maybe plan some forks later who knows
i think
but the extra four minutes i'm gonna
take the risk and jinx that i don't
think ludwig is gonna throw again
yeah this is already a huge advantage
and no more pieces left that can be
blundered it's only the night that could
be left hanging but i think with less
pieces less trouble also this a pawn is
running now trying to promote if a5 the
black king will catch that pawn but that
also means that if mr beast will not
have a chance to defend on the king's
side great technique
the pepe is in the chat everyone thinks
that just because he lost those pawns no
guys i think he was sacrificing because
he has three freaking past pawns and a
knight it doesn't matter if he loses the
funds on the other side of the board
yes i think he did it on purpose indeed
that that's a technique
that you can use the distant past pawn
to drive the king to that side of the
board and you win on the other flank
all right get the knight out of there
first and foremost
get the knight out of there
he wants to win it as a king and point
second let's block him from going to the
right
the only way we can confirm if there was
something
is if we get a stalemate
i think it will be a very unlikely
scenario that ludwig doesn't win this
end game he seems to know and be very
sure of what he's doing in the singing
opponent game he didn't even want the
knight to be part of it
he's got the whole back row
always looking for squares he's very
overwhelming i go here
there's a whole back row
actually let's just go around let's go
here let's let's promote there
interesting king maneuver you got all
these two are yours oh wait oh god wait
wait if he goes way too close
if he goes to f8
he can still still mate
wait did you just see what he arrowed he
literally just arrowed that he wants to
bring his king to f8 am i the only one
who saw that
i saw it too and that's what i'm saying
that he can still steal it if he
actually executes the
arrows
i was joking about the bribing um but
maybe maybe i was right
mr b speeded himself up wait right now
why are we definitely just doing it for
content there's no way if i play g7
then i'm attacking this now he's
switching this guy's protecting doing
the king blocks this square
and it's attacking this square
there's no way he doesn't know how to
win this
in fact it'll be okay he's super
cautious about not stalemating now he
realized that that king went over
the next one is not the best
imagining the king is here
my pawn is here
uh arrows
he's going ludwig mr b forced to go down
trying to call him
okay he didn't
all right
no stalemate and nothing not noticing
that his opponent is trying to make a
phone call
okay check
as long as
okay i think he got it he can take me
here
but it doesn't matter i'll get a queen
now he has to be careful though because
if the king comes closer that is a
stalemate
i mean
i've only heard of a few people who
didn't answer mr b's phone call it did
not end well for them you always pick up
the phone when mr beast calls
very true
what are you
doing the money you could get is much
higher than this prize fund
there we go
checkmate on the board what a comeback
by ludwig mr beast applauding
performance in the second game
all right looks like we're gonna have a
very exciting tiebreaker the first one
of the tournament i can't wait and
they're both very speedy players
this game had it all ludwig was mainly
in control but he did have a couple of
moments where he gave the chances back
to mr beast and i think that final
blunder of the bishop for mr bishop f5
that was where that really hurt him he
was just back in the game fought his way
back and then he blundered the bishop
away but as you said andra this means
that we're gonna have our first ever tie
breaker in [__] chance four so we're
gonna give the players a few minutes to
get ready for a sudden death blitz game
it's going to be three minutes with two
second increment and the first player to
win a game will win the match let's tune
in with a lot we can see his preparation
and how he feels now
yeah best from game one and two gets a
pick i assume it's me right i have a
i crush him that game
oh what
okay you know what i think he gets the
higher cap score
what is that dude
holy [__] i threw a [__] quarter
oh i got smoked
all right well he's gonna start with the
white i got a piss
my god all right what's the time rule
i'll figure it out
[Music]
i'm nervous
oh my god i've never been so stressed
out in my life
stay with me
[Music]
better cap score
stay with me
[Music]
i don't know the cap scores but i think
he crushed me enough game one that it
don't matter
[Music]
oh
oh [__] [__] [__] [__] okay no nothing
leaked nothing leaked nothing leaks
nothing leaks nothing leaked nothing
leaked oh my god
my god
that why did it automatically go and
immediately oh that was terrifying that
was terrifying
thank god there are more numbers
he did call me i didn't even notice
i got three missed calls
hey that just proves i'm not cheating
hello hey i was gonna say hurry up and
end me jesus it took you like 45 minutes
to kill my last little piece there at
the end dude i was
i was nervous all right
well i'm winning this next game sorry
for beating him
why does he have to be better
than vhs
why
like can i have one thing
all right he's got every single sector i
am in better than me he's better than me
at youtube all right he's better than me
at making mogul moves my catchphrase is
mogul moves
that's a [__] joke next to mr beast
okay does more charity better at me and
poker
all right
well ludwig was telling us how mr beast
is better than him at everything but
ludwig i think you look better in a cat
suit
in the cat mate suit which is
what the players have agreed on
absolutely high stakes from their
twitter banter andra thank you for
reminding us on it's not just for the
20k first prize but also who's gonna
wear that cat mate suit mr beast agreed
to
the
additional stakes that ludwig has
suggested and now he has the white piece
as a reminder this is the tiebreaker the
rapid match it was 1-1 both have won one
game each and now whoever wins this game
or the next game whoever wins the first
game who is winning the match overall
three minutes with a two second
increment it's a lot shorter time
control let's see who's gonna be the
speedier and more accurate player was
that mr beast clearing his throne i kept
hearing my ear
[Laughter]
ludwig has abandoned his beloved
scandinavia and he no longer pushed d5
here on the first move i went for the
more classical e5
yep i mean he didn't do well with uh e4
from the black pieces but i think he's
much more comfortable now
[Music]
more tunes
the accompany this very very tense game
everything is on the line in this blitz
game
questionable
stay with me maybe this was his plan
[Music]
if i take here and he takes
let me go here
[Music]
bolster my defenses
oh my god there's only three minutes ah
oh my god oh what
i was wondering why nothing is taking
he now has realized that it's a blitz
tie breaker indeed it's no longer 10
minutes
and then go here
[Music]
but now i'm a bit worried if he places
that bishop on a4 it would be trapped
with b5 he comes back to c4 that's the
better decision to not not let the
bishop get trapped and locked in oh
wow ludwig is training off his strong
dark skirt bishop he's going for this
pawn push maybe thinking he's gonna get
this d4 but
uh now he's created a huge weakness on
the e5 square
at the same time he's got the tempo here
he's got the initiative with the capture
attacking the bishop and and there could
be further pawn pushes in the center i
think he's doing great because the king
of mr beast is still in the center let's
see if he will play e4 or different go
aggressive and isn't this bishop trapped
now actually i missed this after a6
can't come here if it comes here it's
getting forked
yes i think andrea that was the
explanation of the evaluation by showing
so much advantage for why but
for black story i mean for ludwig it
would have been the right plan a6 as you
pointed out the bishop running out of
space it wasn't spotted d4 actually
gives space to that bishop it looks like
a strong move but not as strong as
getting that free piece
yup now mr beast gets to save this guy
a6 no longer works um bishop's just
gonna retreat i do like what you said
about the king in the center but i think
if mr beast gets his castle in the next
few moves he can play against this
weakness now that he's not going to be
down a piece
indeed he could turn the tables if he
gets to castle and then the e5 pawn will
be hanging
bishop g4 because of the pin it still
looks scary if black gets to push e4 but
there's also a pin over the e5 that e
pawn cannot take on f3 not without a
bonus gambit
all right oh i'm making arrows but
they're not showing there we go yeah
there were quite a few pins i mean here
i think white could have even taken here
but
okay we're trading putting the queen on
the strong diagonal like you said this
pawn is pinned a nice rook file right
here putting pressure on d4 lots of
peace activity here
i started to like this position now more
for white because white is out of
trouble after costly those pawns of
ludwig are looking very strong in the
center but they also started to become
really vulnerable the d4 pawn will be
hanging after the queen moves let's
listen with love we can see what he
thinks or hear what he thinks about the
situation
oh my he's worried about bishop b3 but
that bishop is hanging
the time ludwig
45 seconds left both players are below a
minute
see through mister biscuit has the right
idea to try to get the bishop into the
game if d3
bishop takes pawn would be beautiful
but no time
but if he doesn't see it then his bishop
is hanging on b5 so he has to find
bishop takes d3
but both queens are hanging this is a
crazy position with no time for either
player
mr beast dropped that bishop he missed
that black could take with check and his
counter attack did not work but now he
just needs to play the clock he has 23
seconds
he doesn't have time to sing indeed
he has to move the bishop there's only
one squad he's giving up the bishop too
now he's gonna be two pieces down i
think ludwig will not let this chance
slip fit two pieces up
uh see he just needs to play try to
pre-move everything stop this pawn bring
those pieces together oh god the rook
but
by the way has quite a time in village
he doesn't see it though
he didn't take on a two now there's no
past pawn it's not that scary for white
anymore except for the time
the time and the two extra nights this
is now also the rook with the night
fight loving is taking every single
piece one by one ludwig is cleaning it
up
he
i mean i know that mr beast played some
bullet but i think ludwig had a huge
upper hand here
yes and he he put a lot of pressure on
mr beast which he managed to dodge for
quite some time but in the end with that
hanging bishop and the queens being
traded in the wrong way
he ended up being down on material that
was so much material up it it could only
be this miraculous past pawn that
somehow if it gets through the seventh
rank will it make it yeah
it's b7 but now b8 is a threat that b62
is a threat
wait a second oh my god
two squares to promote two squares to
promote so he can't stop both oh he's
going to the wrong square with the king
now the knight can move away with a chat
check oh god oh no that
[Music]
absolute miraculous comeback it could
have been
i mean yeah black's gonna clean up the
pawns and we're gonna have literally
what just happened in the last game
exact same end game
um and ludwig has plenty of time
compared to mr beast but that was insane
he just he didn't have time to double
check you know
yeah with such low time for both
obviously this is a three minute plus
two second incremental it's game a lot
faster time control than the regular pog
champs time control it makes sense that
neither player has spotted how dangerous
that be postponed became it almost ended
up being the absolute hero of the story
yep
well i don't think he's gonna you know
last time ludwig was baiting the
stalemates
but he knows exactly what he's doing
he's bringing out the king
could
still potentially be stalemate but no
ludwig has no mercy literally 50 wait oh
there was increment i didn't realize
there was increment yes there's a two
second increments of three minutes plus
two seconds increment he has now
collected a lot of time went all the way
up
[Music]
i love mr b's reaction oh my god dude
i think i'd admit it on the clock i
didn't realize that time was added i got
nervous yeah exactly
he got nervous he didn't realize the
increment that makes now more sense why
he was so fast when he actually
collected a lot of time but that means
that the match
i think ludwig just really wants to
spend time with mr beast this is why
he's given us two tie breakers i think
so too this is gonna go home for a long
time
buddies now step away michael's cause
they're no longer best friends it's mr
beast now the new best friend the new
chess best friend of ludwig maybe a
little more cat suits together
cutie cinderella europa later
i like cannot crack him
he says he can i cannot crack this
[__]
he doesn't quit
cute and mr beast just giggling in the
background laughing to himself
this is epic i cannot believe it andra
let's replay that final move oh actually
oh my god they're not waiting game on
game one they are not waiting this is
now the second blitz tiebreaker well
they gonna be playing until someone wins
the game so sudden death means whoever
wins first is winning the entire match
as a tiebreaker both players will get at
least a point the loser gets a point
because of scoring in the rapid but we
are ready now for the second southern
death blitz game where ludwig will have
the white pieces
i'm starting to think they made a deal
ludwig wanted to squeeze the longest
youtube video possible from this match
um and mr beast agreed makes sense in
the end they are big youtubers so
i think i know what's going on it's all
about creating amazing content that's
what they're doing right now what is
this
why is the time thinking hello
we need to call him mr beast maybe you
could call him but we set the time back
obviously since ludwig didn't realize
that the game started it's fair that it
goes back to three minutes but we'll
miss the bc now that he has to make a
move too i didn't see that joke i came
up with it on my own chat this time shut
up all right hopefully oh god we know
hopefully we don't have the same thing
the bang the bang and you know if let me
learn anything from his last game he'll
see the check but he probably didn't
analyze
okay so he doesn't go for the capture he
deviates from something that worked very
well for him
in the previous game even if he didn't
immediately spot why it was working
well this is a pause sacrifice now but
if mr beast castles or plays queen e7
yeah both are interesting
this is looking nice and now the rules
have reversed mr beast is eyeing the
file of the kings he's looking nice for
black oh actually no evil bar is in
white's favor yes because white can push
d4 to support the knight and chase away
the bishop but ludwig didn't see it
neither did i it's embarrassing
it's all right andrea you don't play
these open i only played the line of the
london city i don't know
only the elitist push just the d pawn
and never ever do anything else all
right
way more
[Music]
a very symmetrical position equal
material equal
in every possible sense
but we need to see who will develop
their pieces faster and more efficiently
[Music]
mr beast really likes to play these
counter
attacking you
he does he he instead of moving the
bishop
away and he doesn't double check them
either
he's just very fast
but it worked out well for him in the
first game that he was really brave and
went for the attack and now this rook on
the second rank is impressive
will he take on c2 and that can go to c7
point at the same time
i'm [__]
bishop b7 is a good move too to develop
and might take on f3
94 i like by loving your fans of playing
it although i'm just realizing maybe i
should have liked it
attacking both he could still get out of
it by going back to e3 with the bishop
so now the rook goes oh my god is up to
the light square then it will be
attacking the knight and the bishop will
not wake
in case of looking for will not big spot
that there there's a way to save the two
pieces
and now
beast could eye the g2 square
that would be a very nice thrill
bishop 33 is a very important move that
little because spotted this was the only
way in which he could
basically save both pieces
so
rook a4 look at that
active play he looks like those pieces
yeah he really does that's true
okay nice defense i would love to see
some sneak attack over here on g2 with
the bishop eyeing and potentially the
rook
a nice c6 again a great move because it
develops the only piece that was still
sitting on the background this is such a
classically traditionally very well
played game by both players we are
seeing an opposite colored bishop and
game what
i know no this i mean they have both
been playing okay never mind mr beast
has been playing way above his level
today
did he start at 1200 or something
remember
they have been playing very well this is
a different
difference
yeah this is blitz ratings now ludwig
didn't play his best in the first game
but he made a really important comeback
in the second game so overall i think
from the second game when we can say
that they have played above expectations
mr b certainly playing above his own
expectations
oh this bishop can't move i guess you
could go to d2 but oh god not another
stalemate stephen they're going to
simplify everything
ludwig really likes to simplify here but
g5 so aggressive and yes if that pawn is
taken that's what andrea said that rook
on e1 is hanging with the two rooks
attacking king f1 well spotted that you
need protection more protection on e1
is no longer following from mr b's
tricks
g4 jimmy going for the attack even in an
end game will he play g3 jeez are trying
to undermine
bishop's protection dude this plan i
don't know if that was his plan from the
beginning but this is genius
indeed
so whether pawn takes or palm push the
bishop drops said the logic should not
touch that f phone should play something
else leave it there i think now
oh
okay it looks like the line is trading
the rooks and then once you trade
everything white can win the pawn on g2
i mean sorry could it be the case the
mover there will matter though he takes
on f2 first and that allows the bishop
to guard e12 so now the gt pawn will no
longer be left alone he had to start
with the check and he could have won a
pawn and had a favorable endgame but
this is still very close
yeah although with opposite colored
bishops even a pawn up wouldn't be that
big of a deal unfortunately these end
games are very difficult to win
that's true
typically opposite colored bishops are
draw but i think at this level i'm
assuming at a time pressure that'd be a
blunder but maybe they're slowing down
using the increment i'll be careful
so focused both of them not saying a
word
this is now a rook trade maybe a second
rook trait to going full
on in that bishop and game where both
have it very difficult to
to win also to lose you would
practically need to blunder a piece i
think in this situation for making it
losing
do you predict the draw oh maybe i maybe
i jinxed it because now the white king
can make it to the king side the gt
point is hanging but so is the f5 pawn
neither of them are taking a gun
anything gets sacrificed the bishop is
hanging now mr b stakes
so i'm assuming black all they have to
do is just keep this pawn defended
yeah so you gotta keep that pawn
defended and going back to b6 wasn't
really needed that allows white to get a
bit more space maybe push before in the
right moment still should be very
difficult for white to win but in a blue
game both of them on 40 seconds
what happened
this looks like another draw to me i
mean
they're both defending all their pawns
they are here to play the whole night
they really want this budding friendship
to continue through chess games
i mean i'm just at this point i don't
believe that there wasn't a deal like
this would be the third
third tie break i don't understand
there's no way it's not for content
and it's no way it's not for that cat
mate so let's not forget maybe they want
to wear it together oh [__] though
is a mistake it allows my god to create
a past form by taking it and then
promote it you can't even i was wrong
i stand corrected
i'm always next to peace making a
mistake in the final moment he was
holding on for so long he had to just
move his bishop around and just
patiently wait
ludwig is not pushing the pawn just yet
well if he's not pushing us back
black can stop it it's not completely
over especially if if uh mr beastman
used to take the c pawn no he's not in
time ludwig pushed it
yep he didn't give him this pawn even
that
uh white would have had the correct
bishop to win that end game once he
sacked but very
ludwig is playing very carefully he's
not giving him any chances being
extremely careful defending the pawn and
then he will push to see pawn
good technique here by ludwig who put a
lot of pressure on mr beast in
a drone end game but even drone and
games under time pressure you can make a
mistake and that pump push off mr beast
the c pawn push was the big mistake he
knows it he knows that he might not get
another chance at the stalemate with the
queen down i mean with ludwig's
performance today if i was mr b sides
him 50 50.
he's been hopeful but no i think ludwig
has learned his lesson too many times
today
i think he learned that i think this
will lead to a checkmate he's taking the
last pawn of mr beast making sure that
he cannot lose on time
or even if he loses on time he wouldn't
lose the full point
yep i had a feeling you know he wants to
feel confident he knows how to check me
with two queens there we go nice
that was such an impressive match
what did i do
what a relief for ludwig
but it looks so relieved that was the
[__]
hardest chess game i have ever played in
my life
and weldon mr beast what a fight this
has been
that was crazy i mean i have to say i
completely underestimated mr beast and
after today i will never do it again i
can't wait to hear what they have to say
in the interviews
we will be joined by the player shortly
and yes this has been mind-blowing the
way mr beast has basically surpassed
everyone's expectations including his
own expectations of his play we almost
had a third tiebreaker this has been
such an epic battle and we can't wait to
hear the thoughts of ludwig and mr b so
in a moment in a very short moment the
players will join us and until then
here's a bit of a reminder on our
charity initiative
[Music]
no
oh man
and we are being joined by the heroes of
today's show mr beast and ludwig we
thought that this match would never end
we were so close to a third tiebreaker
ludwig congratulations but let me also
congratulate your opponent because mr
beast it felt like you surpassed your
own expectations what a match it has
been
yeah it was funny because uh before the
match you guys said like what was it
they bet three million points on blood
100 000 on me i was like oh no no i now
i gotta win that's funny
i liked when you pointed out chat and
you said none of you believed in me i
mean
okay have you been doing like undercover
training with hikaru or tell us the
secrets i thought you've been playing
poker
yeah i mean it's the same as last year
look you're you literally do the same
thing every single day i know your first
25 moves like the back of my hand i'm
not going a single other match the rest
of this tournament but here's what you
do against ludwig right he's going to
move his pawn in front of his king you
move yours in front of your queen or no
you're sorry if you're white you move
your pawn from your king he moves one
from the queen you take it he takes this
queen you move your night i know the
first 25 minutes i honestly could have
pre-moved them all but i was worried you
would notice and then so i had to like
literally sit here and count to ten and
then move and then count to ten and
there's like a part where there's a free
pawn and i didn't take it because i
still had 10 more moves to make and i
was just like we're doing these uh and
like i just had someone literally study
your last like 200 games and like you do
the same thing every time it's hilarious
so like we were at the exact spot 20
moves in that i knew we were going to be
in i'm not going to stand for this
defamation yes it is true that i do the
same moves but last year i thought you
were like into chess because queen's
camp it just came out i thought you were
like i'll hype on it this year all right
i've been seeing you been into a lot of
poker and you texted me i have no idea
what i am doing you're deaf going to win
ha ha so i was like oh this jabroni is
going to be you had it
you did you could have literally moved
like any other pawn in the game and i
was screwing i'd be like trying to take
a pawn that's not there and be like oh
what do i do my plans are
that's well i i had prepared lines
because you have a secret account i had
prepared lines for what your main
account does because you do the same
thing as me i don't have a secret
account wait what so you just studied
you just looked at the lines and just
remembered it danny helped me and then
it's it's literally predictable it's
like it's here let me here i can
literally if i'm looking at chessboard i
can say it out loud what i'm supposed to
do okay no please don't wait this is
move my bishop in the hole knight pawn
other bishop queen knight um and there's
nothing wrong with memorizing an opening
i i memorized the first fifteen
movements
that was funny day one you lit me up
yeah well then that the other time i was
white you didn't do it so my whole plan
fell apart yeah well obviously i
realized pretty quickly that you knew
every single thing i was going to do so
then i was like oh i don't know what i'm
going to do so if i don't know what i'm
going to do he doesn't know what i'm
going to do if anyone else is playing
ludwig in pugs just let me know i can
show you exactly what to do
we got along pretty well i got you a
blindfold how about that you can make
your first 20 moves go use the bathroom
come back and okay all right all right
i'm surprised it worked that well
especially after i did it last year but
this year i just had a way better idea
we just like last year only did like
three or four movies this time i just
did 20. yeah you've rolled me game one
i'm so
i was so nervous the rest of the games
do you even have nerves anymore
oh i was beyond nervous my hands were
sweating really can i tell them about
our conversation can i tell twitch chat
go for it about poker because
uh we were talking right before the
match i was literally on the toilet five
feet away from me right now pooping and
i was texting jimmy and jimmy was like
oh you're you're so gonna win and i was
like [__] yeah i'm gonna win
little did i know and then we were
talking about poker and i've seen you've
been he's been playing with tom dwan and
phil hellmuth who are like the best
poker players legends
and uh and i'm like yeah all you do is
play poker uh if you ever want to do
heads up let me know just has like some
consolation in my mind i was like he's
been pressing poker i'm gonna destroy
him in chess and then i'll go play him
in poker and then he says he says this
and i quote 100k heads up
and i'm like bro i can't do 100k the sum
of thought's over and then i say 10k he
goes no i need you to be nervous
it's true poker is easier when your
opponent's nervous yeah but i feel like
you don't succumb to nerves as much i do
i was i was i was freaking out that
entire that's why i stale made in game
three
i almost made a game four right guys
i feel like
we were we were worried that you might
be close but you clinched it and you
were so much more cautious
yes but this was an incredible match as
you said ludwig the first game
mr b said all in on that attack you said
going in with the force and you
literally were checkmating a lot of x
king it was a miracle logic that you you
got away with it there were a few missed
opportunities there and it ended up
being a minor piece end game
yeah that's when i realized i was like
wait this guy literally prepared
everything because he had no idea
there was like five check mate
opportunities i saw them you missed
every one i was like wait this guy has
no idea what to do after move 20.
that's always preparation
i was told after move 20 to just jam
everything on the side your king would
so like it was basically everything was
ready and then the second you castle is
just like move move put everything on
that side of the board and just pray
it worked hey look at the end of the day
uh the two content creators in this
tournament have to put on a show after
the resident sleeper
hey hey
in tech tone matches yeah we did have
some brutal slaughter earlier on today
so yeah ludwig that's why you were
playing yeah yeah that was it yeah yeah
yeah
it was all about the content obviously
we wanted to save the whole chess.com
team we really appreciate it i did have
a question for you though you always
like flons you know you have robert hess
you're the most prepared for anything
even when you're playing me hand in
brain i didn't know what to do how do
you feel that you really got out
prepared by a man who put his repetition
on his phone and just read it like a
little notebook
all right look
jimmy came to my turf and damn near
[__] me up
i'm ready to go to your turf and see if
i can take you down all right and we'll
see i'm gonna prepare as hard as i can
forget about chess forget about that
prep i'm willing to do
your 25k heads-up match
and i'm going to prepare for you so hard
i'm going to study i'm going to dm phil
hellmuth and wait for him to reply to me
fervently
she's just going to have the first 20
hands pre-played in your head yeah but
actually i'm gonna like remember exactly
what pieces i i wanted 10k chat he said
nothing under 25k or he won't do it
because i need to be
let's do it that or as long as i get
white every time i'm down to play chess
i had no idea what to do when i was
black pieces because we only prepared on
white side i don't want to put it on
chess i can't my heart can't handle
playing your chest i literally won a
chess tournament last weekend all right
beating everyone's ass sal dosh
you're the one person i'm scared of in
chess now i'm not playing
you literally said you can't crack this
man mr beast you are the new arch enemy
of ludwig
this is what it's insane it felt like
the match was never gonna end it's just
me too it's just me too the other people
it's like he doesn't even practice for
it
i don't care it's only him and the sad
thing is next year he's gonna know so
he's just i i can't win next year
i wish i could admit it's just so funny
now i don't know what to do with this
information hey next time we play i'll
just promise to do the same opening line
i mean can you yeah oh it just keeps
going in my head pawn for you mr beast
i'll do it for you pawn bishop it's like
reading a bedtime story for you it is
it's just like going repetitive in my
head because i didn't look at the notes
while we were playing so i just was like
the leading episode i was like pawn take
knight
fun fact if you do that with the other
players you will literally just win
they you'll destroy them
and are we going to get to see mr beast
in a cat suit
uh i never have high stakes
show me where i agreed to this i don't
know i read it somewhere on the internet
people are saying it on twitter you
might as well
i saw signed mr beast
like i said unlike ludwig i don't have a
cat made outfit at my house
i will buy one and fly to you and put it
on you i mean i love it getting a little
bit more intimate if i get a spend a day
with you then i mean
deal deal
we might have a screen capture yeah
where is it i said unlike you i don't
own a cat made outfit that's not me
agreeing well no you said you said you
said if i get white first you know
there's an implication hey i'm gonna
show up to your place with two cat made
outfits and we'll do hand-in-hand cat
mates yeah 99 of my followers not
watching this they're going to be like
what the hell
it'll go on my instagram so no one will
ever see it oh okay i think so livehead
yeah at the end of the day i think
ludwig just wanted to spend a lot of
time with mr beast as we could have seen
from all those tiebreakers
thank you guys and congratulations
ludwig for the hard-earned win mr beast
with an outstanding performance we'll
see you guys have a rematch in the poker
for ludwig's gonna be playing with the
price of his house putting his life on
the line i'm sad what do i do with this
information
i'm not a good chess player i just only
know how to beat ludwig that's it well
that's the only thing the same thing in
poker and beat my ass there i pretty
much play the same way every time i just
i have a plan for you mr beast though
because if you two make it to the same
bracket of the tournament you can still
face each other in the championship
bracket someone needs to beat him
just
train and play
oh yeah i got it right here you just
post them on twitter okay they get
accessible
dm to go [__] off yeah
poor robert going down against danny as
a coach
he's on his vacation in the bahamas
tournament we're good now
don't you feel a little bit stranded now
ludwig no coach
you know what here's my thing i already
won the rivals event so if i lose this i
just have to say i won the rivals event
and i don't care about this that's fair
that's fair how much i guess you know
you raise money for charity but what is
it i've had to fund again
uh it's like what's the first place all
i care about the money for this is
recouping what i'll lose in poker yeah
you could actually get almost enough to
play a poker match with mr beast if you
want one is it 25k for first i think
it's like 20.
you need a few more subs to add to it
maybe another short subathon
[Music]
first place pogchamps and looks like
that's a poker game all right
interesting interesting cool this is
good information to have
all right thank you for having me thank
you guys so much for joining us and all
the best for the rest this is epic
pleasure jimmy
pleasure as well later boys
what a mess this has been andrea we
thought it was never gonna end this
budding friendship chess bodies mr beast
and ludwig i think magnus carson is
truly being replaced here because he
used to be the best chess body of ludwig
but
they just kept going kept playing
that's the collab i'd like to see mr
beast and magnus carlsen the competition
yeah that would be crazy but we do have
a lot more action coming up tomorrow
park chance for continues every single
day basically we're gonna have i am
christina
one of the top spanish streamers facing
the magic the gathering genius croakies
tomorrow as our first matchup mr beast
will be back tomorrow all ready to fly
against five up and rubios will also
have this time his second match against
pawns two of the spanish participants my
students and mr beast maybe with another
brilliant preparation for tomorrow what
do you think i mean i'm never gonna
underestimate him again but it's not the
same you know he doesn't have his
notebook that he can use against five
ups so five up's also been pretty good
i've been seeing his chest so that'll be
a a little bit more difficult without
the preparation
that is true that is true so huge date
tomorrow for mr beast five up and also
visit the spanish community facing
croakies and ruby's opponent is pawns
that is going to be the show for
tomorrow a reminder that we have
obviously all the initiatives that we
have been mentioning our charity
initiative our sponsor shout out to
coinbase and eternal and you guys will
be left in good hands tomorrow with a
different team of casters i believe
andra you and me will be back in the
future but not for tomorrow we have a
rotating squad and we cannot wait to see
you guys tomorrow for the show awesome
new faces coming tomorrow i'm looking
forward to commentating with you anna
it's always a lovely time thank you
again
likewise andrea and i i still can't
believe how this last match was going to
go on forever
for the entertainment of all of us it's
all about the content i'm sure i'm sure
there was no there was no agreement this
has been
an epic epic battle and mr beast
outplaying ludwig being the underdog
without playing him in the very first
game and then ludwig felt like he
couldn't crack him he couldn't get to
this man he couldn't defeat jimmy
and i thank you for the perfect summary
and chat we'll see you guys next time
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
[Music]
you